WELL GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO THE FIRST
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY
COMMITTEE FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION.
I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES AND I SERVICE THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE WITH ME
ARE SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE THAT I
LIKE TO WELCOME.
US STARTING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AT CHAO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRISTY SMITH
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS SO
FIVE AT THIS MOMENT TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUES TO GIVE --
OPENING REMARKS AND WE CAN JUMP
RIGHT INTO THE FRAMEWORK --
THAT WILL BE DISCUSSING TODAY
FOR THIS HEARING.
BEFORE I JUMP INTO OPENING
REMARKS ON THE INTRODUCED OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT OF THE
COMMITTEE TONY SIMON'S --
FOR THE JOBS COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS BAD NO WAR HEIGHT WHICH IS
OUR COMMITTEE SECRETARY WITH THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE --
WE ALSO HAVE A CAITLYN COULD
POLICY CONSULTANT.
SO TWO DAYS OF FOCUS OF THE
HEARING IS AN OVERVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. TO SERVE
AS A BASIS FOR COMMITTEES
EVALUATION OF STATE PROGRAMS IN
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS IN THE
COMING SESSION.
IN THE GLOBAL RACE FOR
INNOVATION AND ECONOMIC GROWTH
CALIFORNIA HAS MANY ADVANTAGES
WHICH HAVE RESULTED IN THE STATE
CONSISTENTLY BEING RANKED AMONG
THE LARGEST ECONOMIES IN THE
WORLD.
HOWEVER AS WE KNOW THE
PROSPERITY HAS NOT BENEFIT IS
NOT BENEFITING ALL SECTORS ALL
PARTS OF OUR STATE IN CERTAIN
CERTAIN POPULATION GROUPS ARE
FALLING FURTHER AND FURTHER
BEHIND.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT UNIQUE IN THIS
EXPERIENCE WITH GROWING INCOME
INEQUALITY.
IN FACT MANY BUSINESSES PUBLIC
POLICY EXPERTS INCLUDING OUR
GOVERNOR HAS PLACED INCOME
INEQUALITY AND ITS RELATED
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
DISTRIBUTIONS.
AS ONE OF THE PRIMARY ISSUES
IMPEDING THE STATE'S LONG TERM
ECONOMIC GROWTH TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE ORGANIZED AROUND THREE
PANELS.
PRESENTATIONS DURING THE FIRST
PANEL WILL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF CALIFORNIA'S TWO POINT SEVEN
TRILLION ECONOMY AND ITS PLACE
WITHIN ITS NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
ECONOMIES.
OUR PRESENTERS WILL ALSO DISCUSS
CURRENT AND EMERGING ISSUES THAT
INFLUENCE THE HEALTH OF OUR
ECONOMY.
THE SECOND PANEL THE PRESENTERS
WILL DELVE A LITTLE MORE DEEPER
INTO THE ECONOMICS AND WORKFORCE
ISSUES THAT DR --
THESE ECONOMIC TRENDS WE WILL
ALSO HEAR ABOUT BILL PROPOSALS
AND INITIATIVES THAT WE MAY WANT
TO SUPPORT AND CREATING THE
CONDITIONS FOR MORE INCLUSIVE
ECONOMY.
THE FINAL PANEL WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. TO ENGAGE IN AN OPEN
DIALOGUE SEEN KEY INDUSTRY
SECTORS SMALL BUSINESSES AND
DIFFERENT REGIONS.
AFFECTING DIFFERENT REGIONS IN
OUR STATE --
BUT BEFORE --
STARTING IN THAT WITH OUR FIRST
PANEL I WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBER SHOULD YOU
HAVE ANY OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY IT'S IT'S A GREAT --
TO BE ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
CONSERVING WITH YOU --
AND IN THIS CAPACITY.
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE WE
DEFINITELY HAVE WORKED ON AS
COUNTY SUPERVISORS AND WHEN YOU
KNOW COUNTY.
AND WITH THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
ON INCOME A QUALITY OF THOSE
AREAS APPRENTICE PROGRAMS --
UPSCALING WORKERS MAKING SURE
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT IT
HAS ON OUR WORKERS AS WELL AS
INTERNSHIPS WITH LOCAL
BUSINESSES TRYING TO GET --
THOSE ENGAGE EARLY ON INTO THE
PROFESSIONAL ARENA WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU IN
YOUR ENDEAVORS ON THIS COMMITTEE.
I THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR FOR HAVING THIS --
HEARING I ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PRESENTERS FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR TO OUR YOUR TESTIMONIES
THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WHAT LET ME FIRST DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE BACK OF A
RIVER REPORT PREPARED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF AMONG OTHER
INFORMATION YOU WILL FIND AN
OVERVIEW OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
INCLUDING LONG TERM ECONOMIC
TRENDS.
A LIST OF RELATED LEGISLATION
FROM THE CURRENT AND PRIOR
SESSIONS A LIST OF RELATED
REPORTS AND FOR THE RESEARCH AND
BIOGRAPHIES OF EACH OF THE
PANELISTS --
SPEAKERS TODAY AND WHEN AN ITEM
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION --
ON AGENDA ITEM FIGHTS PLEASE
SIGN IN AT THE BACK WITH OUR
SERGEANT AT ARMS.
SO IF WE CAN BEGIN WITH OUR
FIRST PANEL OR I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME JOHN ROSS FILLED AND
CAROLINE SHUE.
AND WITH IT WE RIGHT UP HERE
PLEASE.
SO AS A SPEAKERS GET SETTLED IN
LET ME FIRST I INTRODUCED JOHN
ROCK FILLED INVESTMENT TO
DIRECTOR AND HAD ECONOMIST OF
CALPERS INVESTMENT OFFICES --
PRIOR TO JOINING CALPERS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE MISTER ROCKFORD
HAD. EIGHTEEN YEAR CAREER IN
GLOBAL MARKETS RESEARCH AND
STRESS STRATEGY AT BANK OF
AMERICA MERRILL LYNCH AND BEFORE
THAT FOR CHICAGO BANK --
IN THE AUSTRALIAN TREASURY
INCLUDING A STINT AT THE
INTERNATIONAL MONETARY FUND IN
WASHINGTON DC --
GIVEN THE TECHNICAL NATURE OF
THIS PEN I'M GOING TO ALLOW
MEMBERS TO ASK CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS AS WE GO THROUGHOUT
THIS PRESENTATION.
OKAY AND CAN I ASK HOW MUCH TIME
IS INVOLVED --
FOR THIS PARTICULAR PANEL I
COULD EVEN GO TO FIVE MINUTES OR
TWO HOURS I BELIEVE WE HAVE
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR FOR THIS --
AND LET ME SEE --
OKAY GOOD --
SO AT THANK YOU FOR I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY --
KILLED
HOUSEHOLD OWNERSHIP --
WAGE INCREASES FOR RELATIVELY
LOW INCOME EARNERS AT THAT
STARTED TO FEED INTO THE
ECONOMIC EXPANSION THAT WE'VE
HAD -- SO I
WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW THE THE
BACKWARD LOOKING FOR ME WAS
PRETTY GOOD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT --
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THIS IS.
SEVENTEEN AND THIS IS
PRELIMINARY DATA BECAUSE OF THE
SHUTDOWN IN THE IN IN IN IN --
WASHINGTON --
WE DON'T HAVE FULL DAY YET FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT COMES OUT
THE TWO DAYS FROM NOW.
BUT IT LOOKS AS THOUGH THE
ECONOMY AS I MENTIONED EXPANDED
FROM A TWO AND A QUARTER PERCENT
RATE TO A 3% RIGHT.
A LITTLE BIT MORE CONSUMER
SPENDING WE ALL GOT A TAX CUT
LAST YEAR --
SOME OF US TO DISAPPOINTED BY
THE REFUNDS WE GETTING BUT IT
LOOKS AS THOUGH WITHHOLDING WAS
TAKEN DOWN SO PEOPLE HAD MORE
MONEY TO SPEND --
THE GOVERNMENT ALSO GOVERNMENTS
ALSO STARTED TO SPEND A LOT MORE
SICKLY STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BUT ALSO FEDERAL SPENDING ON
DEFENSE --
BUT STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
HIRING AND CAP EX IN OTHER FORMS
OF SPENDING IN THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL ALSO WENT UP --
QUITE STRONGLY IN THE ONE AREA
OF THE ECONOMY THAT LOOKED LIKE
IT WAS ACTUALLY WEEK IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WAS HOUSING.
AND WE HAD SOME MORE DANGER OUT
TODAY SHOWING THAT HOUSING
STARTS WITH VERY WEAK TOWARD THE
END OF THE YEAR SO.
HOUSING IS CLEARLY AN AREA OF
THE ECONOMY THAT HAS SLOWED DOWN.
IN PASTA CANONIC CYCLES THIS A
CONCERN.
BUT IN THIS CYCLE WE'VE HAD SUCH
A SLOW RECOVERY A SLOW AND
MEASURED RECOVERY IN HOUSING.
WE HAVEN'T HAD --
AN EXCESSIVE USE OF MORTGAGE
DEBT FOR HOUSEHOLD EQUITY LINES
OF CREDIT THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE
PAST CYCLE BUT BECAUSE THE WHOLE
ECONOMIC EXPANSION BLOW UP.
WE'VE HAD A MUCH MORE MAY SHOULD
IMPROVEMENT IN HOUSING A LOT OF
IT IS BEING IN THE MULTI SPACES
POST A SINGLE FAMILY.
AND SO --
THE SLOWDOWN RECENTLY IT'S BEEN
DUE TO A VARIETY OF FACTORS ONE
IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
BEING SPENDING MORE RAISES
INTEREST RATES SO KIND OF CROWDS
OUT SOME OF THE ACTIVITY.
IN HOUSING IS ALSO A BIG
SHORTAGE OF CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
BY HOUSING --
YOU CAN SEE THAT IN JOB ADS IN
HOUSING A VERY STRONG YET THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EMPLOYED HASN'T
GONE UP.
ANYWHERE NEAR AS MUCH AND OTHER
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION COSTS HAVE
GONE UP ABOUT 50% IN THE LAST
YEAR SO.
X. IT'S EXPENSIVE TO BUILD A
HOUSE IT'S EXPENSIVE TO FIND
WORKERS AND HIGHER INTEREST
RATES OF COURSE TO SLOW DOWN.
BUT WE DON'T THINK THE SLOWDOWN
IN HOUSING --
IS THERE ARE SOME SIGNS OF
HOUSING COULD HAVE A BETTER YEAR
IN. TWENTY NINE TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AT IMPROVING THE
ECONOMY LAST YEAR.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MATTER
THROUGH INTO FINANCIAL MARKETS
IN FACT THE STOCK MARKET HEADED
DOWN YEAR WHY IS THAT.
IT'S PARTLY BECAUSE THE THE
STOCK MARKET TENDS TO BE FORWARD
LOOKING SO.
WE DID HAVE A VERY GOOD --
A YEAR FOR THE ECONOMY TWENTY
SEVENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT THE
MARKET SO WORRIED ABOUT TWENTY
NINETEEN BUT THE BOND AND THE
STOCK MARKET WHICH IS WHAT WE
LOOK. FOR THE RETURNS IN IN
CALPERS PORTFOLIO SO WHAT WHAT
ARE PEOPLE WORRIED ABOUT ONE
THING THAT AGAIN CHAIRMAN PAL.
MENTION TODAY IN THE SEMI ANNUAL
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY.
WAS HAVE THE POLICIES AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
LED TO A QUICK A RAIN TO THE
EXPANSION BECAUSE IT'S GIVEN THE
ECONOMY A SUGAR HIGH IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OR IS THERE A
SUPPLY SIDE REVOLUTION IT'S A
LOT OF THIS KIND OF DEBATES WE
WERE HAVING --
IN IN THE REAGAN YEARS IS THIS A
SUPPLY SIDE REFORM OR IS IT
ADVANCE SIDE.
AND SO.
A COUPLE OF THINGS WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT IS LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION.
LAST YEAR --
WE WE GOT A LOT MORE FOLKS
INTERESTED IN LOOKING FOR JOBS
WAGE RISES STARTED TO IMPROVE.
AND SENTIMENT SURVEYS WERE
SHOWING SOME PEOPLE FELT VERY
COMFORTABLE THERE WERE PLENTY OF
JOBS OUT THERE FOR THEM.
AND THERE WAS ALSO A LOT MORE --
BECAUSE GOING ON THE ECONOMY AND
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE WE STARTED
TO SEE THE BENEFITS OF THE
STRONG LABOR MARKET FEEDING
THROUGH INTO LOWER INCOME CO
HOLDS.
THE FEMALE LIFE PORTAL FORCED
PARTICIPATION WENT UP VERY
SHOPPING --
STICK WITH THE TWENTY FIVE TO
THIRTY FOUR YEAR OLD AND ALSO
FOR LATINO HISPANIC --
GROUPS IN THE LABOR FORCE SO
THAT WAS VERY ENCOURAGING BUT IT
HAS TO CONTINUE.
ANOTHER ONE IS PRODUCTIVITY AND
ANOTHER ONE IS --
DOES THE FED HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY --
TO ALLOW THE ECONOMIC EXPANSION
TO KEEP GOING AND THAT'S BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT SINCE
DECEMBER WAY FED CHAIRMAN PAL --
SAID THAT THE FED COULD AFFORD
TO WHITE.
AND CALIBRATE ECONOMY A LITTLE
LIST MECHANISTICALLY THAN IT HAD
BEEN FILLING ON WHEN IT STARTED
TO RAISE INTEREST RATES.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT LIKE FED
CHAIRMAN GREENSPAN IN THE MID
NINETEEN NINETIES TO SO THE
ECONOMY STARTING TO BACK OFF
WHEN THEY RAISE INTEREST RATES.
AND THEY BACKED OFF RAISING
RATES IN FACT I CUT RATES IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND NINETY
NINETY EIGHT SAID THAT FIT
FLEXIBILITY.
IS ONE REASON THAT PEOPLE WILL
BECOME THE FOCAL --
ONE OF THE SO I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION --
IN IN BULLET POINT FORM THREE
FOR THE CHALLENGES WHY ARE THE
MARKETS KIND OF WORRIED ABOUT
EIGHTEEN ONE OF THE REASONS IS
THAT THE US ECONOMIC EXPANSION
IS GETTING VERY LONG BY JUNE IT
WILL BE A RECORD. TEN YEAR
ECONOMIC EXPANSION.
JAPAN'S IN FACT NOW SEVENTY FIVE
MONTHS A POST WORLD WAR TWO
RECORD OF AB SEVENTY FIVE MONTHS
AND SOME OF THE OTHER ECONOMIC
EXPANSIONS AROUND THE GLOBE
LOOKING LONG IN THE TOOTH.
THAT BELIEVE THAT MEANS THAT
THERE START TO BE HEAD WINS
AGAINST ECONOMIC GROWTH RATHER
THAN TAIL WIND SO.
THE MATURITY OF SOME OF THE
ECONOMIC EXPANSIONS IS A PROBLEM.
ANOTHER ONE IS OF THE LABOR
MARKET IS VERY TIGHT AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOOKING FOR WORK --
IS IS GETTING VERY VERY LOVE SO.
WE NEED TO THINK A AND THEN FED
CHAIRMAN PAL ALSO MENTION THIS
IS MORNING WE START WE NEED TO
START THINKING ABOUT INNOVATIVE
WAYS. TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO
LOOKING FOR JOBS WITH THAT'S
GOING INTO PRISONS WHETHER IT'S
GOING --
INTO THE OPIOID --
PROBLEM PARTICULARLY WITH THE
YOUNG MALES WE WE DON'T HAVE THE
POOL OF LABOR THE DRAWER ON YET --
THE WE HAVE BEEN FEMALES --
IN IN IN THE LABOR FORCE SAID.
NOW THAT PROBLEM CLEAR ITSELF UP
A LITTLE BIT IN TWENTY EIGHT TO
EIGHT BUT THAT COULD JUST BE
TEDIOUS SOCRATIC.
ANOTHER PROBLEM IS TO THE U. S.
ENGAGED IN A TRADE WAR GLOBALLY
NOT ANY WITH CHINA BUT WITH YOUR
NOW WE SAY THAT WE CAN BE IN
THAT WINDOW FROM THAT BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ECONOMIC DATA.
TYPICALLY U. S..
THE US ECONOMY IS HIGHLY
CORRELATED WITH GLOBAL TRADE.
SO I COOL AND WE START TO SLOW
DOWN GLOBAL YEAR OF THE TURNING
AND SALES AS WELL.
AND THAT'S A BIG THING WITH THE
LOCAL AT THAT THE US INVESTORS
HAVE BEEN WORRIED ABOUT --
THIS YEAR.
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT.
EVEN THOUGH DIRECT TRADE IS ONLY
A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF OUR
ECONOMY.
S. AND P. FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES
45% OF THE STYLES ARE APPROVED
SO THEY PRODUCING A BROAD INTO
FOREIGN MARKETS SO.
THAT THEY START TO SEE A TRADE
WAR -- THEY
THEY THE CORPORATE SECOND FLOOR --
CHINA SLOWDOWN IS ANOTHER BIG
ISSUE AND AND THE YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS A PARTICULARLY
WHEN WE CATCH WITH CHINA.
CHINA'S ECONOMY HAS ACTUALLY
SLOWED DOWN THE EFFICIENT NUMBER
SAY SIX AND SIX AND CHANGE.
SOME OF THE MORE AGGREGATED
PARTIALLY BECAUSE THIS IS SAYING
CHINA'S ANY GROWING 32425% --
CHINA HAS PLENTY OF LEVELS IN
WHICH TO TRY AND IMPROVE ITS
FARMING.
THE SOMETHING CALLED IMPOSSIBLE
TRINITY WHICH SAYS THAT CHINA
CAN'T CONTROL EVERYTHING.
AND RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS AS THOUGH
THEIR STARTING --
TO BOTTOM OUT THE IS THAT --
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO IN TIME TO PREVENT A BIGGER
SLOWDOWN IN CHINA'S ECONOMY.
THE U. S. FEDERAL DEBT
TRAJECTORIES BIG ISSUE --
YOU EXTEND HIS BRIAN --
SHOCKLEY SAN USUAL FOR THIS
STAGE OF THE BUSINESS CYCLE WILL
BE -- FOR
THE US TO BE RUNNING SUCH.
A LARGE LEVEL OF ANNUAL DEBT.
AND ON MARCH ONE WE HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE EXTENSION OF THE
DEBT CEILING WHICH IS BEING
SYSTEM FOR AWHILE.
AND IN FIVE FINALLY --
ONE MORE I WILL MENTION IS THAT
CENTRAL BANKS AROUND THE WORLD
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND NINE HAVE BEEN
ADDING LIQUIDITY TO THE GLOBAL
SYSTEM THROUGH.
BUYING PHONES ESSENTIALLY AND
THAT GETS INTO BANK RESERVES SO
IF HE PROVES YOU BELIEVE BANKS
TO LEND Là IT ENDS UP IN HOUSE
PRICES.
IT ENDS UP IN STOCK AND BOND
RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT A POINT WHERE
THE EUROPEAN CENTRAL BANK HAS
STOPPED DOING QUANTITATIVE
EASING THE FED IS ACTUALLY
REVERSING ITS QUANTITATIVE
EASING.
SO THERE'S A BIG LIQUIDITY
IMPACT ON THE WORLD.
WHICH SAY THE GROWTH WILL NOT
NECESSARILY GOING TO GET --
A GOOD OUTCOMES --
FOR FINANCIAL MARKETS AND THAT
LEADS INTO CONSUMER BEHAVIOR AND
CORPORATE BEHAVIOR IF FINANCIAL
MARKETS ON STRONG.
SO OVERALL I WOULD SAY --
YOU KNOW TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS A
GOOD YEAR --
FOR THE U. S. ECONOMY --
BUT FINANCIAL MARKETS AND AND IN
GENERAL WHEN YOU WE LOOK FOR WE
START TO SEE SOME MORE PROBLEMS.
BASED ON THINGS LIKE MATURITY OF
THE CYCLE --
FEDERAL DEBT --
AND THINGS LIKE THAT ARE CAUSING
PROBLEMS --
AGAIN MY MESSAGE WOULD PROBABLY
BE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTIES MORE CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT THE WILL BE SO --
UP UNTIL NOW IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS OF THE ECONOMIC
EXPANSION.
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
QUESTIONS --
IF MISTER ROTH OF THE THOUGHT IS
OKAY I DON'T KNOW IF ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS MOMENT
HAVE ANY YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER I FEEL THAT
WITH WHAT INFORMATION TO FIT IN
IN THE TIME THAT YOU YOU
MEASURED IT BUT THANK YOU I'M IF
I WAS WONDER IF YOU COULD PLEASE
SPEAK TO SPECIFIC CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY SECTORS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE GOAL GLOBAL
TRADE WAR --
WE AT AGE IT THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU --
CAROLINE MAY BE MORE LIKELY TO
TALK ABOUT I'D I I WORK IN THE
AREA OF THE CALPERS WHICH LOOKS
AT THE BIG MORE MACRO
ENVIRONMENT SO --
I DON'T REALLY HAVE A FEEL FOR
WHICH INDUSTRIES HAVE BEEN MORE
AFFECTED OBVIOUSLY THE TRADING
GAUGE WENT HAS BEEN.
MORE ONEROUS FOR THINGS LIKE
TECH.
AS OPPOSED TO THE FOLKS WHO MAKE
SERVICE SECTOR GOODS --
SO -- IN
THIS LATEST ROUND OF REPORTING
BY THE S. AND P. FIVE HUNDRED
COMPANIES WE ACTUALLY PEOPLE IN
HEALTHCARE AND LUXURY GOODS
SILES WAITRESSES ENGAGEMENT WITH
CHINA IS ACTUALLY GOING REALLY
WELL.
SUCH A REAL BIFURCATION I THINK
BETWEEN TAKEN INDUSTRY
MANUFACTURING VERSES SERVICE
SECTOR WHICH OF CHINA'S TRY TO
RE BALANCE OUR ECONOMY MORE --
MORTARBOARD SCHOOL WOULD --
SERVICE SECTOR PURCHASES --
THAT ENGAGEMENT IS ACTUALLY BEEN
FAIRLY POSITIVE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN EARLIER YOU
MENTION ABOUT THE SLOWING
HOUSING MARKET --
YOU MENTIONED YOU MENTIONED
SEVERAL FACTORS THAT SO
BASICALLY ARE CONTRIBUTING TO
THE TO THAT SITUATION.
DIMENSION RENT CONTROL AND THE
YOU KNOW.
UP -- I
NOTED THERE WAS SOME CONCERTED
EFFORT AT ALL WORKING ON THE
RENT CONTROL WHAT KIND OF ROLE
WITH THAT PLAY INTO THE
OVERRIDING QUESTION IF ANY --
WELL I I MEAN WE THE WAY WE LOOK
AT IT IS WE ARE NOT PRESCRIPTIVE
WE WE BASICALLY TAKE THE THE
LANDSCAPE THE WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY
IF YOU HAD --
SOME KIND OF DILUTION OF RENT
CONTROL --
THAT COULD SEND OUT MORE OF A
SIGNAL FLOW WARD TO WARD MORE
BUILDING AT CENTER.
BUT IT IT DOES SEEM TO BE A
NATIONAL PROBLEM THE THE
BUILDING PROBLEM THE SHORTAGE OF
WORKERS THE THE HIGH COST OF
BUILDING A HOME THAT'S RIGHT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ANY OTHER PROBLEM QUITE FRANKLY
IS THAT --
IF YOU LOOK AT SOMETHING CALLED
A HOUSING OPPORTUNITY INDEX
WHICH TAKES A HUNDRED CITIES
HUNDRED TWENTY CITIES AROUND THE
U. S..
LOOKS AT WHETHER THE MEDIAN
FAMILY CAN AFFORD TO BUY A HOUSE
IN A JURISDICTION WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF MEDIAN FAMILIES --
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF HOUSE OF SOUL
CAN BE FOR AREA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LIKE LOS ANGELES AND
SAN DIEGO THOSE NUMBERS ARE
INCREDIBLY LOW --
SO WE ALREADY HAVE THE EXTREMELY
HIGH PRICES IN THOSE
JURISDICTIONS.
SO -- I'D
HAVE TO THINK MORE THROUGH THE
IMPACT OF SOME KIND OF DILUTION
OF RENT CONTROL WHAT IMPACT THAT
MIGHT HAVE ON THE SUPPLY PASSES
BUT AS I SAID --
CALIFORNIA HOUSE PRICES IT IS --
GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE WITH
ALMOST OF THE HISTORICAL.
NORM AFFORDABILITY --
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU.
MR ROSS GOT A QUICK QUESTION
WHERE ARE THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ENHANCE OUR GLOBAL
COMPETITIVE COMPETITIVENESS.
WELL I WOULD SAY --
I'D I'D SAY THAT --
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE AREAS OF
GROWTH WILL INCLUDE --
SAID THE THE STATE DEVELOPING
SERVICE CHECK AROUND THE WORLD
SO MEXICO TRYING OR ITS ADDRESS.
THE EMERGING MIDDLE CLASS IN
THOSE COUNTRIES --
THE SIGNIFICANT áP APPETITE WE
GEOGRAPHICALLY DISPOSED TOWARD
BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT THESE
COUNTRIES IN TERMS OF HEALTHCARE
AND OTHER SERVICES.
AND SO -- I
I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY THE AREA
THAT WE MORE LIKELY TO BE ABLE --
TO TO ENGAGE BETTER AND THEN OF
COURSE IN THE IT WORLD --
IT REALLY WE REALLY COLLATERAL
DAMAGE OR WHATEVER OF WATER
COMES OUT OF THE THE ENGAGEMENT
BETWEEN WASHINGTON AND THE THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
JUST A FEW MADAM CHAIR JUST ON
THE THE 45% --
INVESTMENT ABROAD THAT THE S.
AND P. IS DOING.
AND THAT --
STARTS TO LOOK AT THE
PROJECTIONS AS FAR AS THE
DIFFERENT CALCULATIONS THAT WE
SEE.
HOW -- HOW
VISUAL IT SHOULD WE BE OF
KEEPING TRACK OF WHAT IT IS THAT
THE --
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING AS
IS DISCUSSING WORLDWIDE --
DISCUSSIONS WITH DIFFERENT
NATIONS AND HOW THAT AFFECTS US.
I THINK THERE I THINK IN GENERAL
THERE WAS SOME ISSUES --
THE CHALLENGING ISSUES CHINA --
BUT I THINK WE DON'T WE DON'T
WANT TWO CHASE A STRAW MAN AS
FAR AS THAT GOES BECAUSE THE
ARRANGEMENT WE HAD WITH CHINA
GOING ON SINCE THEIR ACCESSION
TO THE WORLD TRADE ORGANIZATION.
TWO THOUSAND THREE HAD A LOT OF
MUTUALLY.
SO -- IF YOU
KNOW THE US SUPPLYING --
AS CHINA SUPPLYING.
CONSUMPTION --
FOR IMPACTING CORPORATE PROFITS
AND AND THEN ALLOWING --
YOU KNOW THE THE THE BETTER
PERFORMANCE OF US CORPORATE
SECTOR.
BUT THERE IS ALSO SOME DOWN
SIDES OF THAT YOU KNOW WHICH OR
HOLLOWING OUT OF MANUFACTURING
SECTOR IN THE U. S. AND SOME OF
THE SIX IS THE US BUT THAT'S
REALLY BEEN HAPPENING GLOBALLY
SO -- THE I
THINK THE MAIN ISSUE IS TO GET
AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPACT
OF THE ENGAGEMENT --
IF IF US CORPORATIONS ARE --
GOING TO BE HURT BY.
THIS AND WE AREN'T GOING TO GET
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
COMPANIES COMING BACK ON SHORE
ESSENTIALLY TAX CUTS ARE BEING
USED. FOR BUY BACKS AND DIVIDEND
NINE SECOND BEING USED TO
INCREASE NECESSARILY HIRING --
CAP EX --
THAT'S THAT THAT'S A PROBLEM.
SO IS THE MAIN THING IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE OUTCOME BUT WE GET
IS BENEFICIAL I THINK TO THE TWO
THE TO THE LOCAL ECONOMY PUBLIC
FOR THE CORPORATE SECTOR BUT
ALSO WE WANT TO SEE.
A GREAT A HIRING AS WELL AS A
PROBLEM IN THE US ECONOMY IS WE
WERE VERY TIGHT ON HIRING ANYWAY.
WE HAVE A VERY TIGHT SUPPLY OF
LABOR RIGHT NOW SO.
I WOULD SAY THAT WE SHOULD BE
MORE LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE OLD.
IN WOOD MIGRATION --
PROGRAMS TO BETTER EDUCATE
AMERICANS --
IN ORDER THAT IF WE ARE GOING TO
GET A SHIFTING OF SOME
PRODUCTION BACK ON SHORE AND
THAT THAT IS DONE --
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW IN A WAY THAT --
WE HAVE SKILLED WORKERS. TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
SO BETTER FOCUS I THINK OF THE
POLICIES WOULD TO IMPROVE.
THE OUTCOMES OF THE ENGAGEMENT
WE DOING CHINA.
THANK YOU AND RESTORE FINAL
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR --
THE HOUSING DO YOU THINK THAT
THERE'S A THE IMPACT AS FAR AS
THE THE MAXIMUM LOAN AMOUNTS
THAT ARE BEING OFFERED THROUGH
FHA LOAN SOME OF THOSE DIFFERENT
THINGS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
ARE IMPACTING THE THE OWNERSHIP
OF OWNS AND SOME OF THE BUILDING
OF THOSE PHONES BECAUSE IT'S OUT
PACING SOME TO QUALIFY. FOR THE
AMOUNT OF THOSE HOMES ARE.
I I I THINK THAT AFTER THE
FINANCIAL CRISIS IN IN --
IN TWENTY TWO THOUSAND ITEMS ARE
JUSTIFIABLE --
CAN'T A REACTION WHICH IS THAT --
WE GOT INTO A CRAZY LEVERAGE
CYCLE WHERE --
THEY WERE THE THERE WAS A LOT OF
LENDING GOING ON NOW --
I THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
FACTORS WHY HOUSING IS BUDGET
BEING A MUCH SLOWER.
AND THEREFORE MORE COMFORTING --
GRADUAL IMPROVEMENT IN THE SOCKS.
IN THE CRAZY SOCCER WILL BE
HEADING IN THE MID TWO THOUSANDS.
ONE OF IT IS ACCESSTO LOANS I
THINK --
KIND OF TALK TO STAND ITS OWN
WHEN.
THERE'S ALSO NUMBER A NUMBER OF
OTHER FACTORS AS WELL --
INCLUDING.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE CHANGING AT
TASTE AWARD MULTI UNIT.
LIVING AS OPPOSED TO SINGLE
FAMILY --
THAT THAT KIND OF CHANGE THIS IS
GOING ON NINE AND ALSO --
YOU KNOW PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
THE SUB PRIME PRIME.
BANKRUPTCIES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BASICALLY GOING BACK INTO
RENTAL SPACE.
SO I THINK THIS A NUMBER OF
THINGS ONE OF IT IS PROBABLY
IMPEDIMENTS TO LANDING --
BUT WE CERTAINLY WANT TO AVOID
GOING BACK TO THE KIND OF CYCLE
WE HAD BACK IN --
I CAN THE ONLY TWO THOUSAND AND
AND QUITE FRANKLY YOU KNOW WE
THE CONSUMER SIDE IS IN MUCH
BETTER SHAPE THAN WAS IN THE TWO
THOUSANDS.
THERE ARE POCKETS OF CONCERN
LIKE THE OUTSTANDING LEVEL OF
STUDENT LOANS WHICH I THINK IS
ABOUT ONE FOUR POINT FIVE
TRILLION.
SO MAYBE SOME POLICY CHANGES AND
THEY DID THEIR OF SOME POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS --
WHAT WE WOULD PROBABLY LIKE TO
SEE IS --
HOUSING HAVING A BIT OF OUR IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS WHERE
WE ARE STARTING TO GET HIGH
HOUSEHOLD FORMATION.
WE ARE STARTING TO GET LOWER
INCOME GROUPS BY --
OWNING HOUSES AS OPPOSED TO
RENTING SO SOME OF THOSE THINGS
ARE QUIETLY GOING ON IN THE
BACKGROUND.
THAT I THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE ECONOMIC CYCLE GOING A
FEW MORE YEARS TO ALLOW THAT TO
BROADEN OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER ROSS FILLED FOR
THE PRESENTATION TODAY I LIKE TO
INTRODUCE OUR NEXT SPEAKER
CAROLINE CHU.
WHO IS THE DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OF STATE AND LOCAL
FINANCE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IN THIS
CAPACITY MISS CHIU LEADS THE
OFFICE WORK ON THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY STATE REVENUES OVERALL
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES?
PENSIONS AND EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ISSUES AMONG OTHERS PREVIOUSLY
MYSTERY WORKED AS THE US DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT AND THE RAND
CORPORATION MYSTERY THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AND PLEASE BEGAN
AT YOUR LEISURE --
SO GOOD MORNING THIS MORNING I
WAS ALSO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THE CALIFORNIA ANYWAYS
SPECIFICALLY AND THEN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY PLEASE AND
THE STATE REVENUES --
SO -- AS WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED CALIFORNIA IS
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
PUNCHES A LITTLE BIT ABOVE ITS
WEIGHT IN TERMS OF ITS ECONOMIC
OUTPUT COMPARED TO ITS
POPULATION ARE WITHIN THE
COUNTRY.
ABOUT CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
ABOUT 12% ABOUT OF THE NATIONAL
POPULATION BUT HAS ABOUT 40%
PERCENT --
OF THE NATIONAL ECONOMY.
SO LOOKING CALIFORNIA JOBS THIS
CHURCH SHOWS YOU THE UPPER
PORTION OF JOBS FIVE SECTOR IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHAT YOU
CAN TAKE AWAY FROM THIS CHART IS
THAT JOBS AND HEALTH THEM ARE
PRETTY SPREAD OUT ACROSS A
VARIETY OF SECTORS THERE REALLY
ARE -- A LOT
OF ASPECTS --
OF THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY WE
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE AN
ECONOMY THAT IS --
FOCUSED ON ONE PARTICULAR TYPE
OF I'LL PUT LIKE AGRICULTURE OR
OR I. T. WE WE HAVE AN A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT --
STRINGS.
THIS CHURCH SHOWS YOU THE
PROPORTION OF JOBS IN PARTICULAR
SECTORS THAT ARE IN CALIFORNIA
AS COMPARED TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY SO.
LOOKING AT THIS.
AND SEE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
HIGH PROPORTION OF CERTAIN
SECTOR JOBS SO I'M SURPRISINGLY
CALIFORNIA HAS OVER 50%.
OF THE NATION'S JOBS IN MOTION
PICTURES SO THAT'S DOWN IN LA
AND HOLLYWOOD OF A HIGH
PROPORTION OF THE COUNTRY'S
AGRICULTURAL JOBS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PREDOMINANTLY --
AND ALSO A HIGH PROPORTION OF
THE COUNTRY'S --
ATTACKER I. T. JOBS IN WEB
SEARCH AND INTERNET PUBLISHING.
OVERALL THOUGH THE STATE ONLY
HAS ABOUT 11% OF OF JOBS NATION.
SO THIS NEXT CHART --
SHOWS TWO DIFFERENT THINGS THE
FIRST SHOWS THE PROPORTION OF
JOBS -- BY
AREA IN THE STATES SO AS YOU CAN
SEE ALMOST HALF THE STATE'S JOBS
ARE IN THE GREATER LOS ANGELES
REGION.
AND THEN ABOUT A QUARTER OF JOBS
ARE IN THE BAY AREA.
IF YOU LOOK DOWN AT THE NEXT
CHART HERE IT SHOWS YOU THE
CONCENTRATION OF PARTICULAR
SECTORS IN PARTICULAR AREAS OF
THE STATE SO THIS REALLY BREAKS
OUT.
ARE THE WAYS IN WHICH CERTAIN
REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA REALLY
HAVE KIND OF A REGIONAL SPECIFIC
ECONOMY THAT HAS A PARTICULAR
FOCUS.
SO IN THE BAY AREA AND THERE IS
A HIGHER I. T. AND AND
PROFESSIONAL AND TECHNICAL JOBS --
AND THEN IN THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES REGION WHICH IS REALLY A
GOODS HUB FOR THE STATE THERE'S
A VERY HIGH PROPORTION OF THE
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION
WAREHOUSING JOBS.
UNSURPRISINGLY SACRAMENTO --
HAS A HIGH PROPORTION OF STATE
GOVERNMENT JOBS AT ALMOST 25%
AND THEN --
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY HAS OVER
HALF THE STATE'S AGRICULTURE
JOBS.
SO WITH INCOMES IN CALIFORNIA
OVERALL CALIFORNIA INCOMES ARE
HIGHER THAN THE REST OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THE MEDIAN INCOMES IN CALIFORNIA
IS ABOUT SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS AT LEAST OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER NOW.
I'M IN CALIFORNIA'S --
HIGH INCOME EARNERS ALSO EARN
HIGHER THAN THEIR PEERS ACROSS
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF THERE'S A
FAIR AMOUNT OF VARIATION ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF INCOME
THIS CHART SHOWS YOU THE
VARIATION IN INCOME BY REGION
AND THEN ALSO BY INCOME GROUP --
SO AS YOU CAN SEE THE BAY AREA
HAS THE HIGHEST INCOMES OVERALL
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY HAS --
THE LOWEST INCOMES OF THE
REGIONS LISTED HERE YOU CAN ALSO
SEE THE SORT OF THE SPREAD OUT
MISS. FOR HALF OF A BETTER TERM
OF INCOMES THE CHURCHES YOU THE
GEN AND THE TOP. 10% OF
HOUSEHOLDS SO YOU CAN SEE THE
VARIATION BETWEEN THE MEDIAN --
AND THE TOP 10% OF HOUSEHOLDS BY
REGION HERE.
SO MOVING INTO INCOME AND THEN
HOW IT PLAYS INTO THE STATE'S
REVENUE IS.
THE LARGEST SOURCE OF INCOME IN
CALIFORNIA ARE WAGES AND
SALARIES ALMOST A TRILLION
DOLLARS ON THAT'S FOLLOWED BY
CAPITAL GAINS OUT OF A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS AND
THEN --
PENSIONS ANNUITIES AND IRA
DISTRIBUTIONS AND A HUNDRED AND
TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
NOW I'M LOOKING AT HOW THESE
DIFFERENT SOURCES OF INCOME PLAY
IN NEW ON PEOPLE'S EARNINGS THIS
CHART MIRRORS THE LAST ONE SO
THE BLUE SHE ANSWERED OUR
FRIENDLY WAGES AND SALARY AND
RETIREMENT.
INCOME AND THEN THE ORANGE
SHADES ARE CAPITAL GAINS
PARTNERSHIP INCOME DIVIDENDS
INTEREST AND RENTS WERE YOU CAN
SEE FROM THIS CHART IS THAT YOU
MOVE AS YOU MOVE UP THE INCOME
DISTRIBUTION WE STARTED
004-400-1000 DOLLARS AND THEN
THE LAST HOME IS --
OVER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS YOU
CAN SEE THAT THE PROPORTION OF
INCOME FROM WAGES TO CLIENTS AS
PEOPLE'S INCOMES INCREASES IN
THE PROPORTION OF INCOME FROM
CAPITAL GAINS.
PARTNERSHIP INCOME IN OTHERS
REALLY STARTS TO INCREASE.
THEN THIS NEXT CHART SHOWS YOU
THE VARIATION OR THIS SORT OF
VOLATILITY OF INCOME BY INCOME
TYPE AND AND WE'LL TALK NEXT
ABOUT HOW THIS PLAYS INTO
REVENUES --
IN A COUPLE OF SLIDES BUT WHAT
YOU CAN SEE HERE IS THAT WE JUST
AND SALARIES WHICH IS THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF INCOME OVERALL
IS RELATIVELY STABLE AND IT'S
YOUR TO YOUR GROW THIS CHART
SHOWS YOU THE PERCENT CHANGE
YEAR OVER YEAR.
IN CONTRAST CAPITAL GAINS
PARTNERSHIP INCOME THESE ARE
VERY VOLATILE AND ANY CHANGE
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM YOUR YOUR
AGAIN LOOKING AT THE TOTAL
PERCENT CHANGE.
SINCE THE NINETIES --
THE LARGER SHARE OF INCOME TIME
TO THE THAT TO HIGH INCOME
EARNERS THOSE IN AND EIGHTY IF.
THOSE EARNING EIGHTY IN THE
EIGHTIETH PERCENTILE ON ABOVE.
AND AND YOU CAN SEE HERE AGAIN
THE PERCENT CHANGE YEAR TO YEAR
YOU CAN SEE THE GROWTH
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE END OF THE
GREAT RECESSION --
IN THE HIGHEST IN THE HIGHEST
INCOME EARNERS.
SO MOVING TO REVENUES AND WE'LL
GET INTO HOW ON THE GROWTH IN
THE HAITIAN EARNERS PLAYS INTO
THE STATE'S OVERALL REVENUE
SYSTEM IN JUST A SECOND --
THIS CHART SHOWS YOU THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TAX SYSTEM SO THERE
ARE THREE CONCENTRIC CIRCLES
HERE THE FOR THE INNERMOST
CIRCLE SHOWS YOU THE SPLIT --
IN TOTAL TAX REVENUE BETWEEN THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF STATE.
OF TAX REVENUE GOES THE STATE
AND ABOUT ONE THIRD GOES TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. FOR THE
STATE'S REVENUE THE LARGEST
SOURCE OF REVENUE IS THE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX WHICH YOU
SEE IN IN THE SECOND CONCENTRIC
CIRCLE.
AND THEN ON IN THE OUTERMOST
CIRCLE THOSE --
HI SLICES SHOW YOU THE SOURCES
OF THOSE --
OF THOSE REVENUES SO AGAIN
PERSONAL INCOME TAXES YOU CAN
SEE THE LARGEST OUT ON PORTION
OF THAT HIGH IS WAGES AND
SALARIES --
AND THEN THEY'RE ALL THE OTHER
COMPONENTS OF INCOMES INCOME AND
THEN SIMILARLY ON THE
CORPORATION TAX AND THE SALES
AND USE TAX YOU CAN SEE HOW.
THE SOURCES OF THOSE TAX BREAK
OUT ACROSS DIFFERENT DIFFERENT --
TYPES OF OF SALES OF GOD.
SO SINCE THE NINETIES THE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX HAS GROWN
MUCH FASTER --
THEN THE SALES AND USE TAX AS
WELL AS THE CORPORATION TAX AND
IN LARGE PART THIS IS --
INCOME GROWTH AT THE HIGH INCOME
AT THE HIGH END OF THE INCOME
DISTRIBUTION IN COMBINATION WITH
THE STATE'S PROGRESSIVE RATE
STRUCTURE SO WITH HIGH INCOME
GROWTH. TO THOSE WHO ARE TAXED
AT THE HIGHEST MARGINAL RATES
COMES THE HIGHEST AMOUNT OF
GROWTH IN THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX.
IN CONTRAST TO SALES AND USE TAX
IN THE CORPORATION TAX --
HAVE HAVE GROWN MORE SLOWLY.
SO TALKING ABOUT THE VOLATILITY
IN CALIFORNIA'S --
REVENUES THIS CHART SHOWS YOU
THREE BREAK THREE DIFFERENT
BREAK OUTS --
OF TAX LIABILITY THE FIRST --
COLUMN SHOWS YOU THE SHARE OF
TAX RETURNS BY INCOME GROUP.
SO YOU CAN SEE IN THIS FIRST
BLUE COLUMN IS THAT THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF TAX FILERS OFFERED
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN ZERO AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF INCOME?
WHICH IS THE CENTER --
LATER ORANGE COLUMN THAT FALLS
MORE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DISTRIBUTION IN THE FIFTY TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR RANGE.
BUT THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
LAST CON THE DARK TAX LIABILITY
YOU SURE YOU SEE THAT THE
HIGHEST SHARE OF TAX LIABILITY.
IS --
FALLING TO THOSE MAKING OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS REALLY
SHOWS YOU HOW THE STATE'S TAX
STRUCTURE IS PROGRESSIVE IN
TERMS OF WHO BEARS --
THE OVERALL THE LARGEST SHARE OF
THE TAX BURDEN.
THIS CHART SHOWS YOU JUST A
DIFFERENT A LITTLE BIT A
DIFFERENT BREAK OUT IN TERMS OF
WHO PAYS.
THE LARGEST PORTIONS OF THE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX WHAT DISH
SHOWS ESSENTIALLY IS THAT THE
BAY AREA HE'S A LARGER
PROPORTION OF BEING INCOME TAXES
COMPARED TO ITS POPULATION --
THAN ANY OTHER REGION SO THAT
THE PLOT OF THE HORIZONTAL AXIS
SHOWS YOU THE SHARE OF THE
POPULATION AND THE VERTICAL
ACTUALLY SHOWS YOU THE PERCENT
OF PERSONAL INCOME TAXES PAID.
WHAT YOU CAN SEE IS THE BAY AREA
IS ABOUT 20% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION BUT PLEASE --
OVER 35% OF FOLKS OFTEN ASKED
WHY ON THE SALES TAX HAS GROWN
SLOWER.
IN RECENT YEARS AND IN LARGE
PARTTHAT'S BECAUSE THE PRICE OF
GOODS -- HAS
HAS NOT RISEN VERY QUICKLY --
WHERE IS THE PRICE OF SERVICES
HAVE --
RISEN NOTABLY SINCE THE EIGHTIES
BUT THOSE ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE
SALES TAX ON CONSEQUENTLY THE
SHARE OF TAXABLE SALES --
AT IS A SHARE PERSONAL INCOME
HAS HAS DECLINED SINCE THAT TIME.
LASTLY JUST A COUPLE NOTES ON
CORPORATION TAXES ARM WHICH IS
THE THIRD LARGEST CATEGORY OF
THE STATE'S --
TAX REVENUE.
CORPORATION TAXES ARE RELATIVELY
CONCENTRATED ON THESE TOP FOR AT
LEAST HALF FOUR GROUPS PAY ABOUT
SIXTY PER 68% ALMOST 70% OF
OVERALL CORPORATION TAX BUT ONLY
MAKE UP --
24% OF CORPORATE TAX PAYERS SO
THAT'S MANUFACTURING RETAIL
HOLDING COMPANIES AND FINANCIAL
COMPANIES.
WESLEY JUST ONE NO --
ON CORPORATION TAXES THIS --
SHOWS YOU THE BREAK OUT OF
CORPORATION TAX CREDITS WHICH
SOME ARE SOME OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST TAX CREDITS.
SPECIFICALLY THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT --
TAX CREDIT AT ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS AND THEN IT
SHOWS YOU THE BREAK OUT.
BY INDUSTRY OF OF WHAT CORPORATE.
EVE --
DIFFERENT PROPORTIONS OF THAT
TAX FRIDAY.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR ME.
THANK YOU MISTER DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FROM THAT ONE JUST FOLLOW UP ON
THE SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE ARE
THE FEDERAL.
TAX LAW LAST YEAR WHAT HAS THAT
DONE WITH RESPECT TO THE YEAH
THE CORPORATE DEBT TAXES FOR
EXAMPLE THE NUMBER --
ONE DOWN FROM 39% 221% OF THEIR
ABOUT HOW THAT IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA IS A WHOLE --
SO CALIFORNIA HASN'T TAKE ANY
ACTIONS TO CONFORM WITH THE
FEDERAL CHANGES IN --
TAXOL EITHER ON THE PERSONAL
ORACLE AND THAT SAID BECAUSE OF
THE CHANGES AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IN TERMS OF BRINGING.
BACK HOME WE HAD CALIFORNIA HAS
SEEN.
SOMEONE OF AN INCREASE IN
CORPORATION TAX REVENUE JUST
BECAUSE COMPANIES ARE RESPONDING
TO TO THAT INCENTIVE SOMEWHAT
BUT THERE HASN'T BEEN REALLY AN
OUTSIZED IMPACT ON REVENUES THAT
WE'VE SEEN AS YET THIS YEAR
[inaudible]
THANKS.
A QUESTION --
THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK TO HOW DO
YOU SEE THE STATE'S TRANSITION
TO A LOW CARBON ECONOMY.
I REALLY IMPACT IN OUR ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
WELL I THINK.
IT DEPENDS IT IN TERMS OF HOW
THE STATE.
MAKES THAT TRANSITION ULTIMATELY
IF THE FOCUS IS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES CALIFORNIA FACES IS.
IS --
RELATED TO TRANSPORTATION AND
HOUSING THAT IS INCREASINGLY
PEOPLE LIVE FURTHER AND FURTHER
FROM THEIR WORKPLACE --
AND NEED TO COMMUTE TO TO WORK
I'M SO THAT THEIR IMPLICATIONS
FOR WHERE AND HOW CALIFORNIA
BILLS HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT THAT.
LOW EMISSIONS GOAL.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING US
TODAY I CERTAINLY BEEN A
PLEASURE I KNOW THAT WE MAY HAVE
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS AFTER
TODAY'S HERE IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO JUST TO CONTINUE ON WITH
TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL HEARING --
WALK CALIFORNIA'S CLEARLY A
DOMINANT PLAYER WITH IN THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE STATE AND
POPULATION GROUPS HAVE NOT
EQUITABLY PARTICIPATED IN ITS
PROSPERITY.
CALIFORNIA'S WORK FOR SERVICE
WANTED THE STATE'S COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGES KEY STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS HAVE BEEN ASKED TO JOIN
US TO DISCUSS.
THIS -- AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AN ANALYSIS FOR
USING WORKFORCE IN TRAINING
PROGRAMS TO ADVANCE A PROSPEROUS
MORE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY --
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME
MISTER JIM MAYOR AS OUR FIRST
SPEAKER.
WITH US THIS MORNING MISTER
MAYOR IS THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF CALIFORNIA FORD WHERE HE
LEADS OUR EFFORTS TO SUSTAINABLY
AND EQUITABLY INCREASE
PROSPERITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND MODERNIZE THE PUBLIC'S
RELATIONSHIP.
WITH THE STATE'S GOVERNMENT
THROUGH BY TRANSPARENCY WE HAVE
ASKED MISTER MAYOR TO COVER IN
ADDITION TO WORK FORCE THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ROADMAP. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT
MISTER MAYOR IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
GETTING.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
INVITATION IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
BE IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY.
THAT THE HEADLINE HERE I THINK
IS THAT OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
IN CALIFORNIA WITH ACTUALLY MADE
A LOT OF PROGRESS ON THIS
CENTRAL ISSUE ABOUTHOW DO WE
SUPPORT PROSPERITY.
THAT SIMULTANEOUSLY REDUCES
INEQUALITY AND POVERTY AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY.
ANTS ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY WE'VE GOT A LONG
WAY TO GO BUT THAT PROGRESS IS
AN INDICATOR OF WHAT WE CAN DO.
AND WE IN PARTICULAR THOSE OF US
INVOLVED IN THE SUMMIT BELIEVE
THE TWENTY NINETEEN IS A VERY
IMPORTANT YEAR VERY IN.
CORN OPPORTUNITY.
TO INCREASE THE SCALE IN THE
SPEED AT WHICH WERE MAKING
PROGRESS.
NOT JUST AGAINST THE NUMBERS
WERE NOT SATISFIED WITH NOW IN
TERMS OF INCOME INEQUALITY AN
OPPORTUNITY.
BUT THE CHALLENGES THAT WE KNOW
WE FACE IN THE FUTURE AS WHETHER
IT'S A AYE AND OTHER TECHNOLOGY
INTERNATIONAL COMPETITION.
ON THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICY THAT THE MENTIONED AND SO
WE WERE THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
SETTING UP TO SOLVE TODAY'S
PROBLEMS AND SETTING IT UP SO
THAT WE CAN SOLVE THE PROBLEMS.
FASTER BETTER AND CHEAPER GOING
FORWARD.
I WANNA MAKE THREE MAIN POINTS
FROM GATED SUBJECT THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TAKING ON TODAY THE FIRST
IS THAT.
EQUITABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
PROSPERITY REQUIRES A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION.
THAT'S THE SYSTEM SCALE.
LEVEL RIGHT WE'RE NOT GONNA
SOLVE THIS WITH A PROGRAM WE'RE
NOT GONNA SOLVE IT WITH A
FUNDING SHIFT.
IT REALLY TAKES ALL OF THE
PIECES COMING TOGETHER.
CHANGING FUNDAMENTALLY HOW THESE
PROGRAMS AND HOW THESE POLICIES
AND HOW THEY STRATEGIES WORK.
AND THAT MAY SOUND DON TEAM BUT
AGAIN WE'VE BEEN MAKING US HERE
THAT SHOWS US WE CAN DO THIS.
THE SECOND IS THAT IF WE WANNA
TAKE THESE IMPROVEMENTS TO SPEED
AND SCALE.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FORMALIZE
OUR GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
PARTICULARLY HOW IS IT WE MAKE
THESE DECISIONS NOT JUST HERE IN
THE CAPITAL AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL BUT IN COORDINATION WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN RETURN.
THAT'S THE KEY GOVERNANCE
CHALLENGE WE'VE GOT.
AND WE'VE GOT TO DO THAT IF WE
WANT TO MOVE PAST MARGINAL
CHANGES INCREMENTAL CHANGES.
AND THIRD TO THE PRECISE FOCUS
OF THIS CONVERSATION THERE IS AN
URGENCY TO INNOVATE AND TO
EMIGRATE AND TO ACCELERATE.
ON THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
SOMEONE SPEND JUST A FEW MINUTES
ON EACH OF THOSE.
THREE FIRST BY WAY BACKGROUND
FOR THOSE OF YOU DON'T KNOW
CALIFORNIA FORWARD MANAGES BUT
WE'RE JUST THE MANAGER.
OF THE ECONOMIC SUMMIT ON BEHALF
OF WITH.
THE WHOLE SET OF REGIONAL CIVIC
ORGANIZATIONS --
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF THE
CALIFORNIA STORES AND YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR IN A FEW MINUTES FROM
PAGANI OF THE CEO OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP ONE OF
THOSE REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS.
AND IN ADDITION TO THOSE
REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS OVER THE
EIGHT YEARS THAT THE SUMMIT HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH ATTRACTED A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
ASSOCIATIONS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LEADERS.
THAT HAVE SOMETHING IN COMMON
THEY WANT TO WORK CROSS SECTOR
PRIVATE SECTOR PUBLIC SECTOR
SAID SIX ACTOR.
THEY REALIZE WE HAVE DISTINCT
REGIONAL ECONOMIES AND THEY WANT
TO FIND A WAY TO TAKE WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE REGIONAL SCALE
TO REDUCE.
INEQUALITY AND TO GROW
PROSPERITY AND JOBS AND
CONNECTEDNESS AND THEN TO
CONNECT THAT ACROSS THE REGION'S
AND WITH THE STATE.
AND THIRD THEY ARE PASSIONATE
ABOUT TRYING TO FIND TRIPLE
BOTTOM LINE SOLUTIONS.
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADVANCING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND WAYS
THAT ADDRESS THESE ISSUES OF
INEQUALITY AND INCREASE OUR
SUSTAINABILITY RESILIENCY
THERE'S A FUNDAMENTAL BELIEF WE
DON'T GET THERE BY SACRIFICING
ONE FOR THE OTHER.
WE'RE NOT GONNA START WITH NOT
ENOUGH TO SOLVE CLIMATE CHANGE
IF IT HAD IF IT HAPPENS THAT THE
CONSEQUENCE.
OF JOBS AND WE'VE GOT TO FIND A
STRUGGLE BOTTOM LINE SOLUTIONS
AND THAT'S WHAT BROUGHT THESE
GROUPS TOGETHER OVER THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS EVERY YEAR THERE IS
A SUMMIT LAST YEAR WAS IN SANTA
ROSA.
THIS NOVEMBER IT WILL BE IN
FRESNO --
EVERY YEAR PEOPLE COME TOGETHER
THEY ACTUALLY WORK THROUGH TWO
AND A HALF DAYS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT IT IS THEY WANT.
TO PRIORITIZE IN THE NEXT YEAR
AND THEY PRODUCE A DOCUMENT
CALLED THE ROADMAP TO SHARE
PROSPERITY WHICH WAS INCLUDED IN
YOUR PACKET.
SO EVERY YEAR THERE IS A OF A
NEW ROADMAP THAT SAYS HERE'S
WHAT WE'VE MADE PROGRESS HERE'S
WHAT WE WANT TO WORK IN THE NEXT
YEAR.
AND THEN THEY WORK ON IT ALL
YEAR LONG THIS IS A SO THIS
WHERE EVERYBODY COMES TOGETHER
FIVE HUNDRED OR SO LEADERS
ACROSS THE STATE IN ONE PLACE AT
ONE TIME.
BUT ALL YEAR LONG LITERALLY
HUNDREDS.
OF ADVOCATES EXPERTS AND OTHERS
ARE WORKING TO ACTUALLY ADVANCE
THAT ROADMAP TO SHARE PROSPERITY
IN DEEP PARTNERSHIP WITH
GOVERNMENT AND OTHERS.
LOOK AT THAT ROAD MAP IT IS ED
INCLUDED FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
FOR COURT CHALLENGES.
AND THE NEED TO CREATE ONE MORE
MINUTE ONE MILLION MORE.
MIDDLE INCOME JOBS.
THE NEED TO CREATE ONE MILLION
MORE AT LEAST SKILLED WORKERS.
MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES AND THE
NEED TO CREATE ONE MORE MILLION
ACRE FEET OF WATER EACH YEAR FOR
TEN YEARS IN ORDER TO BRING OUR
WATER SUPPLY TO BALANCE.
WE KNOW THAT THESE NUMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE A LITTLE BIT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WE DID SOME ANALYSIS
WITH MACKENZIE WHO CAME OUT WITH
NEED ONE MILLION MARK AFFORDABLE
JOBS WE NEED THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION MORE AFFORDABLE JOBS.
YOU MAY HAVE MADE HERE THAT FROM
THE GOVERNOR NOW THAT'S WHERE
THAT NUMBER CAME FROM FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S INVOLVEMENT IN THE
ECONOMIC SUMMIT.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
THERE'S BEEN SOME OTHER ELEMENTS
ADDED TO THIS BECAUSE WHAT WE
WERE TRYING TO FOCUS OUR WORK
AGAIN THIS IS REALLY COMPLICATED
WE NEW THAT EVEN IF WE COULD
MEET THE METRIC OF THOSE MILLION
CHALLENGES.
WE WORK ACTUALLY SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE IN FACT THAT
WORKFORCE PIPELINE IF YOU LIKE
THAT TERM BEGINS AT BIRTH.
RIGHT WE KNOW THAT IN THE FIRST
THREE YEARS THE ECONOMIC
POTENTIAL OF EVERY INDIVIDUAL IS
LARGELY INFLUENCED SCIENCE WILL
TELL US THAT WE CAN DO THE
ECONOMICS.
SO OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS THE
FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATIONS WITH IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BECOME INVOLVED
IN THE ECONOMIC SUMMIT SO THAT
THEY CAN START TALKING TO THEIR
BUSINESS AND COMMUNITY LEADERS.
ABOUT THE END OF PORTENTS NOT
ONLY OF THOSE EARLY LEARNING
INVESTMENTS IN LONG TERM
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY BUT HOW DO
WE STRUCTURE AND ORGANIZE THOSE
SO THAT WE GET BETTER RETURNS ON
THAT INVESTMENT.
SO IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT MORE
MONEY INTO THE SYSTEM BUT IT'S A
MORE ABOUT PUTTING MORE MONEY IN
A BETTER SYSTEM THAT GETS US THE
RESULTS THAT WE NEED.
IF WHAT WE NEED IS IS ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO BE CAPABLE OF
DOING THEIR BEST IN THE FUTURE.
UP.
AS AS A AS WAS REFERENCED IN THE
QUESTION AROUND HOUSING THE COST
OF SO MUCH MORE POVERTY PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY DRIVEN.
BY THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SPACE WITH ENGAGE A LOT
OF THOSE LEADERS OVER THE YEARS.
ON HOW IS IT WE CAN BRING TO
INCREASE THE SUPPLY AND REDUCE
THE COSTS OF HOUSING AND I CAN
WE CAN PROVIDE LOTS OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THE WORK WE'VE
DONE ON THAT --
THIS LAST YEAR WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT -- ALL
OF THESE CHALLENGES WE HAVE IN
TERMS OF LONG COMMUTES AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PUTTING
TOGETHER TO MINIMUM WAGE JOBS IN
ORDER TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
ACTUALLY IMPACTS THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIANS AND
SO THIS YEAR WE'RE DOING AN
OVERLAY ON HOW THIS IMPACTS THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH --
IF WE'RE REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT A
TRIPLE BOTTOM LINE WE WANT A
MEASURE THAT IN TERMS OF THE
QUALITY IN THE WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIANS.
AND FINALLY --
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHERE I THINK
THERE IS A PARTICULARLY GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR TRIPLE BOTTOM
LINE IS OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
WORLD COMMUNITIES WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. TO IDENTIFYWHAT ARE
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY RESPOND TO THE
WHAT GREAT INCREASING WILDFIRE
THREATS. TO REDUCE THOSE HAZARDS
TO BETTER MANAGE THE FOREST BOTH
FOR THIS FOR THE SAKE OF A
WILDFIRE IN FOR THE SAKE OF OUR
OF OF WATER SYSTEMS AND AND AND
AND WATERSHEDS BEING MANAGE
BETTER IN A TIME OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
BY IN FACT RECREATING WOULD THE
SUSTAINABLE AND SUPPORT THAT --
THERE'S A LOTS OF INTEREST
INTEREST IN THAT THERE'S LOTS OF
ACTIVITY CALIFORNIA FORWARD IN
THE SUMMIT IS INVOLVED IN THAT --
BUT THAT'S THE THROUGH PUT --
THAT REALLY COULD BE A REALLY
GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO TALK ABOUT.
SO MY SECOND POINT THAT IF IF WE
WANT TO ACCELERATE THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'RE MAKING WE NEED.
TO FORMALIZE OUR GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE --
IN AND THIS CAN THIS IS A LONGER
CONVERSATION AND IS THE SUBJECT
OF SOME THE LEGISLATION THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY DECIDED YOU WANT
TO TAKE ON AND SO --
THE SUMMIT IS --
HAPPY TO OFFER OURSELVES AS A
RESOURCE AND A PARTNER IN
FIGURING THESE THINGS OUT SO AB --
NINE OH SIX BY THE CHAIR WOMAN
AND SOME OTHER MEMBERS OUTLINES --
A PROPOSAL AND PUT PUT FORTH
PROPOSAL FOR HOW THE STATE COULD
GO ABOUT INTEGRATING WHAT WE ARE
ALREADY DOING.
DOING THE EVALUATION OF WHAT
ELSE WE NEED TO DO AND THEN
COMING UP WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN THAT WE CAN PURSUE AN
EMPLOYMENT --
AND IT'S A VERY GOOD STARTING
POINT IN PREVIOUS YEARS THE
SUMMIT HAS SUPPORTED PREVIOUS
VERSIONS OF THIS LEGISLATION AND
WERE EAGER TO ENGAGE.
IN THIS CONVERSATION AS WELL
I'LL TELL YOU THAT THE SUMMIT ON
ITS OWN HAS INITIATED THIS YEAR
WORK ACROSS ITS REGION'S TO PUT
TOGETHER --
A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL OF EXISTING
PLANNING EFFORTS GOOD AGGREGATED
AND BUILT UP SO THAT WHATEVER
THE STATE DOES IT'S TRULY IN
RESPONSE TO REGIONAL NEEDS --
WE'VE ALSO GOT ANOTHER WORK
GROUP THAT SAYS IF IF THIS SOME
KIND OF STRUCTURE WHERE THE
STATE IS CONSULTING WITH THE
REGION'S THE STATUS AND
DEVELOPING A PLAN THIS IS ABOUT
COMING UP WITH A PLAN THIS IS
ABOUT COMING UP WITH ON GOING.
PROCESS PLANTS AND PARTNERSHIPS
TO BE MOVING THIS FORWARD ON AT
THREE SIXTY FIVE DAY BASIS HOW
DO YOU ACTUALLY ORGANIZING
STRUCTURE THAT SO.
WE'RE DOING OUR HOMEWORK ON HOW
YOU COULD ACTUALLY ORGANIZING
STRUCTURE THAT ONLY TO OFFER
THAT IS A RESOURCE FOR YOU AS
YOU CONSIDER YOUR LEGISLATION --
WE ALSO IN THE LAST YEAR --
WHEN WE WHEN WE GET DONE WITH
THE SUMMIT THAT COOK FORMER
CULTURE OF CALIFORNIA FORWARD
AND CULTURE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC SUMMIT --
LEMON DON SAID --
ACCEPTED A REQUEST BY THE
GOVERNOR TO BECOME HIS LEAD.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ADVISOR AND
AND MISTER MADONNA HAS AGREED TO
TAKE THAT ON FOR A LIMITED TIME
IN PART BECAUSE HE WANTS TO TAKE
THE THINKING THAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING BY THESE HUNDREDS OF
LEADERS.
AND WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WITH YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE HERE
TO ACTUALLY FIND A WAY TO
FORMALIZE THAT AND BRING IT INTO
PLACE SO THE TICKET SO THAT THE
AGENCIES.
THAT NEED TO COOPERATE ARE
COOPERATING AND WHERE WE FIND
WHERE THERE'S FRICTION POINTS WE
HAVE A SYSTEM WITHIN THE STATE
THAT CAN RESOLVE THOSE.
SO.
THOSE ARE TWO EXAMPLES OF WHERE
WE SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADVANCE THIS GOVERNANCE ELEMENTS
SO WE'RE GETTING NOT JUST BETTER
IN TERMS OF PROGRAMS ARE
STRATEGIES BUT BETTER AND HOW IT
TURNS WE MANAGE GOVERNMENT
OVERSEE THIS. TO THAT END ONE
FINAL ELEMENT ON THIS SECOND
POINT --
OVER THE LAST YEAR THAT.
THE SUMMIT DEVELOP WHAT WE CALL
THE CALIFORNIA DREAMIN TAX WE
STARTED WORKING ON THIS ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO BECAUSE WE SAID WE
WERE ALL IMPRESSED BY THIS IDEA
THAT A FEW YEARS AGO THE STATE
PUT OUT A METRIC WE WANT TO
REDUCE CARBON.
EMISSIONS BY AXE AND IT DROVE
POLICY IT DROVE INNOVATION IT
DROVE AMBITION AND DROVE IDEAS
AND IT DROVE INVESTMENT --
AND WE SAID WE SHOULD BE DOING
THE SAME EXACT THING FOR INCOME
INEQUALITY UPWARD MOBILITY
ECONOMIC SECURITY --
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AROUND WE
REALIZED BELIEVE IT OR NOT OF
ALL THE DASHBOARDS OF ALL THE
INDICATORS WE ACTUALLY DON'T
MEASURE THOSE WE DON'T MEASURE
THOSE IN WAYS THAT ARE
PREDICATED BACK.
ON THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE ROUTE
DRIVERS OF THOSE INCLUDING
HEALTH AND COMMUNITY HEALTH THE
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
AVAILABILITY OF JOBS AND SO
WE'VE DEVELOPED A PROTOTYPE FOR
HOW YOU COULD ACTUALLY MEASURE
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
IT'S NOT PERFECT IT'S NOT YET
TRIPLE BOTTOM LINE WE NEED TO
GET IT THERE BUT I WANT I WANT
TO SUGGEST AS YOU CONSIDER YOUR
OWN IDEAS ABOUT HOW WE WANT TO
FORMALIZE OUR GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE.
PLEASE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY HOW
ARE WE GONNA MEASURE THIS.
IN A IN AB NINE OH SIX AND
YOU'RE IN THE FIRST DRAFT HERE
THAT WAS SUBMITTED JUST A WEEK
AGO IT CALLS OUT FOR TRIPLE
BOTTOM LINE SOLUTIONS WHICH
WOULD SUGGEST WHEN YOU TROUBLE
BOTTOM LINE METRICS.
SO FINDING A THIRD AND I WANT TO
TOUCH JUST UP FOR A COUPLE
MINUTES ON THIS IDEA THAT.
THERE HAS TO BE AN URGENCY TO
INNOVATE AND A GREAT AND
ACCELERATE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN ECONOMIC AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT --
IT DID CALIFORNIA FORWARD IN THE
SUMMIT HAS BEEN GREATLY INVOLVED
IN THIS WORKING WITH MISTER
LANDER AND HIS TEAM WORKING WITH
THE EDGE COALITION THERE'S LOTS
OF ENERGY AND GOOD PROGRESS THAT
IS BEING MADE BOTH ON IMPROVING
THE WORKFORCE.
PIPELINE CONNECTING THE VARIOUS
SILOS WITHIN THE WORKFORCE WORLD
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE A KEY
ELEMENT TO THIS AND I'VE BEEN
REALLY AT THE FOREFRONT OF THIS --
BUT WHAT WE'VE REALLY DISCOVERED
AS WE IS THAT WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT IN REALLY MEANINGFUL
WAYS HOW TO IMPROVE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN EMPLOYERS
AND THIS AND THE STRUCTURE.
AND IT'S GOT TO BE MUCH DEEPER
THAN AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE IT'S
GOT TO BE MUCH THE DEEPER THAN
OCCASIONAL CONSULTATION --
AND WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE WERE
YOU SEE THE GREATEST GAINS THEY
ARE WORKING A DEEP PARTNERSHIP
TO UNDER DANCE UNDERSTAND THE
SKILLS THAT ARE NEEDED TO DO
VERY TARGETED REMEDIAL EDUCATION --
TO THEN PROVIDE THE TRAINING
THAT'S NEEDED TO GET PEOPLE INTO
JOBS THAT PAY WELL WITH BENEFITS
AND THEN MOVE ON UP THE CAREER
LADDER.
AND NOT ONLY IS THAT FIGHT AND
WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE PIPELINES
BEGAN WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
THE DISCONNECTED USE AND THE
PEOPLE THAT AREN'T SHOWING UP A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DOORS THEY'RE
NOT SHOWING UP AT WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARDS.
THE MOST EXCITING PROJECTS ARE
WE'RE GOOD WILL OR SOME OTHER
COMMUNITY --
ENTITY IS DRIVING IS THAT IS THE
FRONT END OF THAT PIPELINE.
THIS IS NOT ONLY IMPORTANT AGAIN
TO REMEDY THIS CHALLENGE WE HAVE
AROUND FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
MAKING A MINIMUM WAGE AND IT
TAKES TO MINIMUM WAGE IN THE
CHEAPEST PARTS OF THE STATE TO
PAY RENT --
BUT THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO
ALLOW US TO ADAPT THE FIRST
PEOPLE WHO ARE GONNA KNOW THE
IMPACT OF A I REALLY EMPLOYERS
THE FIRST PEOPLE WHO ARE GONNA
KNOW THE IMPACT OF GLOBAL TRADE.
IS GOING TO BE THE EMPLOYERS IF
WARRANTY PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM
OR ABILITY TO RESPOND IS GOING
TO BE MUCH FASTER MUCH GREATER --
AND DISK AND THIS GOES MUCH
BEYOND KIND OF MIDDLE SKILLED
WORKERS ARE ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING THIS APPLIES TO
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING --
ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH OUR
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES AND WE
STARTED TO BUILD THE DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ALLOWS US TO
DO THIS AND THE GOVERNOR IS PUT.
SOME MONEY ON THE TABLE TO DO
DATA INFRASTRUCTURE SO ENCOURAGE
YOU AS YOU THINK ABOUT THAT ROLE
WHAT IS THE DECISIONS WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO BE MAKING WITH
THE DATA THAT COMES OUT OF THIS.
AND ONE OF OUR FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WOULD BE HOW ARE WE
GONNA KNOW HOW AFFECTED THESE
PARTNERSHIPS REALLY ARE.
AND HOW AND AND WHAT ARE THE
DECISIONS THAT EMPLOYERS IN
ORDER FOR THEMSELVES TO BE
PREPARED AND RESILIENT.
SECOND WITH THEM UNDER THIS IDEA
OF OF PARTNERSHIP --
WE NEED TO THINK VERY CLEARLY
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THE EXISTING FINANCIAL AID AND
TRAINING FUNDING AND TURN IT
INTO A REALLY NIMBLE INTEGRATED
IN COHERENT SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
LIFELONG LEARNING --
WE STARTED A WORK GROUP TO WORK
ON THAT THERE'S SOME BILLS THIS
YEAR THAT ARE MOVING THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS HAS PUT FORTH.
A BILL -- BY --
SENATOR LEYVA SB TWO NINETY ONE
THAT WOULD BEGIN TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR CAL GRANT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE ALREADY
WORKING ON WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
HELP YOU BLUE SKY WHAT IS THIS
REALLY LOOK LIKE.
WHEN WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
LIFE LONG LEARNING FOR ALL OF MY
LIFE BUT GUESS WHAT NOW IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO HAPPEN WE'VE
GOT TO FIND WAYS WILL PEOPLE ARE
GETTING SKILLED UP WHETHER STILL
EMPLOYED BEFORE THEY'RE LAID OFF
BEFORE THE I. A. TELLS THEM WHAT
TO DO?
AND AND IN OUR GREAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE C. WEB
AND AND WITH --
REGIONAL WEBS.
THEY UNDERSTAND THIS THEY WANT
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THAT SOLUTION
AND WE WANT TO HELP DO THAT AND
FINALLY THE LAST POINT.
IS -- WE
REALLY THERE'S A LOT --
INVOLUNTARY FREELANCE WORKERS
ARE HOURLY WORKERS ARE GET
WORKERS --
THERE'S PLENTY OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE PROFESSIONAL AND THEY WANT
TO MOVE THEIR LIVES IN THAT WAY
THEY WANT TO CONTROL THEIR
PORTFOLIO WORK BUT THERE'S
PLENTY OF PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT --
SO WE STARTED A GROUP LAST YEAR
TO DO SOME DISCUSSIONS --
THE LONG BEACH WHERE THAN SOME
OTHERS HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
FRAMING UP WHAT THAT REALLY
COULD LOOK LIKE IN TERMS OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN EMPOWER
WORKERS IN THE MARKET PLACE IN
TERMS OF HOW DO WE STRUCTURE CO
OPS ALL KINDS OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO REALLY EMPOWER WORKERS.
AND GRATEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS --
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
ANNOUNCED THAT HE WAS CREATING A
COMMISSION ON CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE IN THE FUTURE OF WORK
TO WORK ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
SO -- DOES
SOME IT WILL WANT TO CONTRIBUTE
IN ANY WAY WE CAN TO THAT
CONVERSATION --
WE THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
CHALLENGES THERE BUT THEY'RE NOT
BLEAK THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES TO EMPOWER ALL
CALIFORNIANS --
TO REALLY OWN ON THAT THEIR
CAREERS AND BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
ECONOMIC SECURITY IF WE GET
THOSE ELEMENTS OF THE SOCIAL
COMPACT AND UPDATE INTO TODAY'S
TRENDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH I MISTER MAYOR IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME IF WE CAN
CONTINUE ON WITH THE NEXT
SPEAKER --
BUT THAT WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS OF
ALL THE PANELISTS --
OF OF THIS SECTION.
THE NEXT SPEAKER WE HAVE ENTER
EXECUTOR FOR YOUR WORK FORCE
ASSOCIATION MISTER LANTERNS
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR AND
NONPROFIT INDUSTRY.
HAVING PREVIOUSLY LED LOCAL
WORKFORCE BOARDS INSERTED IN THE
US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR'S
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
ADMINISTRATION.
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS NETWORKS
OF LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS AND
THEIR PARTNERS WHEN YOU'RE READY
MISTER LANTERN.
I THANK YOU CHAIR CERVANTES
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
REALLY HONORED TO BE HERE WITH
YOU TODAY TO SHARE A COUPLE OF
EFFORTS WE HAVE GOING UNDER WAY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE POINTS
THAT I MISTER MAYOR MADE.
JUST A MINUTE AGO --
REALLY EXCITED TO BE HERE
TALKING TO YOU AT A TIME SUCH AS
THIS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN OUR CURRENT STATE OF OUR
ECONOMY.
THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING YOU HEARD
THAT EARLIER THIS MORNING
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES ARE DOWN UP
AND DOWN THE STATE --
AND IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO REALLY A FACT EQUITY
ISSUES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHILE THERE IS GOOD NEWS ON THE
ECONOMIC FRONT THERE ARE STILL
CHALLENGES THAT CONFRONT US --
CURRENTLY WE HAVE SEVEN POINT
SIX MILLION MIDDLE SKILLED
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA TWO AND A
HALF MILLION OF THEM ARE SET TO
RETIRE ELIGIBLE TO RETIRE IN THE
NEXT TEN YEARS.
THAT'S TRUE 16% OF OUR
POPULATION STILL LIVE AT OR
BELOW POVERTY AND THAT INCLUDES
TWO POINT THREE MILLION CHILDREN
THAT IS A TIME OF YOUNG.
KIDS EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND FAMILIES EARN LESS THAN
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE CAREER CENTERS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED WE HAVE A NETWORK OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY CAREER
CENTERS --
THROUGH THE WORK FOR SPORTS IN
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR WE SAW ONE
POINT ONE MILLION PEOPLE IN THIS
CAREER CENTERS.
MOST ALL OF THEM CLOSE TO EIGHTY
FIVE IT'S WILL BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT.
THESE CHALLENGES NOT ONLY AFFECT
OUR CITIZENS BUT THEY AFFECT OUR
BUSINESSES AS WELL --
ESTIMATES ARE THAT WE WILL NEED
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION MIDDLE
SKILLED WORKERS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND THAT THE
COST OF ON FILL JOB OPENINGS
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA IS
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
SO WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE TALENT
SO WHERE IS THE TOWN.
WILL THE TALENT I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT TODAY LIES IN TWO
AREAS TARGETED POPULATIONS AS WE
LIKE TO CALL THEM --
EXPLAIN IS SECOND.
AND YOUTH YOUNG PEOPLE IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
FIRST I WANT TO SAYTHAT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
AND OUR PARTNERS AND OUR MEMBERS
ARE WORKING HARD TO ADDRESS THE
EQUITY ISSUES BOTH THE SKILLS
GAP.
AND MOVING PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY
LAST YEAR WITH.
YOUR HELP WITH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA'S HELP THE HELP OF
THIS COMMITTEE THE GOVERNOR AND
MANY OF OUR PARTNERS ARE ON THE
TABLE -- WE
SPONSORED LEGISLATION CALLED THE
BREAKING BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE AND ULTIMATELY
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WAS
ALLOCATED OF THE GENERAL FUND.
TO HELP AND TARGETED AT TO HELP
TARGET POPULATIONS.
THIS IS REALLY MET TO TARGETED
FOLKS WHO ARE CURRENTLY NOT THE
TAXED TO THE EDUCATION SYSTEM
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES OVER THE LAST FIVE TO
TEN YEARS INVESTING IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
INVESTING IN K. TWELVE INVESTING
IN HIGH A HUGE PART OF OUR
POPULATION THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY
ATTACHED AND ABLE --
TO TO TO BENEFIT FROM ANY OF
THAT INVESTMENT SO THIS --
THIS IDEA IS REALLY THE BEST OF
BOTH WORLDS IN OUR OPINION IT
PAIRS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS --
TOGETHER TO REACH OUT TO WEAR
THESE INDIVIDUALS FOSTER YOU
HOMELESS DISABLED POPULATION
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS WHERE
THEY LIVE THE CBO'S HAVE THEIR
CULTURAL COMPETENCIES THEY HAVE
THOSE.
THE TRUST OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THE IDEA IS THAT THE CBO'S WOULD
BRING THEM INTO THE WORKFORCE
SYSTEM WORKING WITH WORKFORCE
BOARD WE WOULD REMEDIATE THEIR
LIFE SKILLS AND EDUCATION SKILLS.
WORKING WITH ADULT EDUCATION
SYSTEM WHEN WHEN NECESSARY. TO
MOVE THEM INTO ONE OF THREE
OUTCOMES --
ENROLLMENT IN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION.
ENROLLMENT IN --
INTEREST IN THE CRYPT HALFWAY
JOBS AND THE THIRD WOULD BE
INTERESTED TO PRE APPRENTICESHIP
AN APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THAT PROGRAM IS OFF AND RUNNING
WE'VE JUST CONCLUDED FIVE FORMS
ARE ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OR INTRODUCING --
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN THE BREAKING
BARRIERS INITIATIVE TO THE
COMMUNITY OF CALIFORNIA.
HAVING GREAT QUESTIONS COME FROM
PRIMARILY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT THE RULES --
AND THE ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND
THIS INITIATIVE THAT MONEY WILL
HIT THE STREETS IN THE SPRING
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
COMING BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE.
AND SHARING INCREDIBLE RESULTS --
WITH THIS EFFORT --
FIFTY MILLION EMPHASIZE START.
OKAY SECOND APPRENTICESHIP SO.
CALIFORNIA AS WE KNOW IS THE
DRIVING.
FOR THE DRIVING FORCE OF OUR
ECONOMY IS INNOVATION.
WE ARE STILL THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND NO
SIGNS OF SLOWING DOWN.
HOWEVER THERE IS A MISMATCH THE
TYPE OF TALENT THAT'S NEEDED AND
DEMAND THAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
EMPLOYERS AND THE TYPE OF SUPPLY
THAT'S CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.
WE CAN WORK TO FILL THE CURRENT --
NEED -- BY
MOVING PEOPLE QUICKLY IN THE
JOBS BUT THERE'S A BIGGER
CHALLENGE AND THAT'S THE
PIPELINE TO THE FUTURE FIVE TO
TEN YEARS FROM NOW.
WHERE WE GONNA FIND THAT TALENT
IN OUR NATION'S HIGH SCHOOL
SYSTEM IN OUR STATE HIGH SCHOOL
SYSTEM?
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PLAN WITH
THE STATE WORKFORCE SPORT HAS A
PLAN FOR DOUBLING THE NUMBER OF
APPRENTICES.
BY TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN GOVERNOR
NEWSOME.
HAS UPPED THE ANTE CALLING FOR
AN INCREASE IN NEARLY 5100% AN
APPRENTICESHIP TO THE TUNE OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IN THE
STATE OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND APPRENTICES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. 86% OF
THOSE EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND ARE
IN THE BUILDING TRADES AND FIRE
FIGHTING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
IT AFFECTS OUR YOUNG PEOPLE --
A DISAPPEAR DISPROPORTIONATELY.
THE YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP IN
CALIFORNIA IS MICROSCOPIC POINT
2% OF APPRENTICES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE UNDER EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD.
CALIFORNIA IS THE GLOBAL LEADER
IN THE AVERAGE WEIGHT AVERAGE
AGE OF A PRESS IS.
AND THE AVERAGE AGE OF A PRICE
IN CALIFORNIA IS TWENTY NINE
YEARS OLD --
THAT IS QUITE OLD FOR AN
APPRENTICE AND THAT HAS SOME
ECONOMIC RAMIFICATIONS.
WE KNOW IN CALIFORNIA THAT FOR
EVERY ONE HUNDRED NINTH GRADERS
THAT ENTER HIGH SCHOOL SEVENTY
FOUR GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL ON
TIME. FORTY FIVE OF THOSE
HUNDRED START CALLER BY THE AGE
OF TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO EARNED
A DEGREE AFTER SIX YEARS.
AND ULTIMATELY ONLY TWELVE OF
THE HUNDRED NINTH GRADERS ARE IN
A FOUR YEAR DEGREE.
THE AVERAGE TIME THAT IT TAKES A
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE TO LAUNCH A
CAREER.
IS SEVEN YEARS.
THAT MEANS PEOPLE ARE TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD BEFORE THEY FINALLY
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
THOSE YOU'D END UP OUR
OPPORTUNITY YOUTH IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND OF THEM STRONG.
I HAVE TO LIVING WITH ME RIGHT
NOW.
SO.
I LET ME JUST SAY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IF YOU LOOK AT IF
YOU LOOK AT IT WE HONOR COLLEGE
AND I THINK THAT'S GREAT WE
HONOR COLLEGE FOR ALL BUT I
THINK IT DOES A DISSERVICE. TO
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IF YOU GOOGLE
RIGHT NOW AND I JUST DID THIS
THE OTHER NIGHT FOR PRESENTATION
I'M DOING ON THE FUTURE OF WORK.
IF YOU GOOGLE CAREER NIGHT HIGH
SCHOOL CAREER NIGHT.
AND YOU LOOK AT THE FLYERS AND
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY ADVERTISE
IT'S ALL ABOUT COLLEGE PREP.
I JUST RECENTLY ATTENDED A
CAREER NIGHT AT MY SON'S SCHOOL.
SIXTY BOOTHS TO VOCATIONS MOST
ALL OF THEM WERE COLLEGES FROM
HAWAII. TO NEW YORK CITY --
SO I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
SHIFT THE SCRIPT ON WHAT IT
MEANS ON HOW WE HONOR WORK
WITHIN OUR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
YEAH I'M THE THING ABOUT
APPRENTICESHIP THAT'S SO GREAT.
AS IF WE GET HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
IN A BIG WAY INTO THE WORLD OF
WORK IT BENEFITS INDUSTRY
DRAMATICALLY IT'S MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE TO HIRE AN EIGHTEEN
AND NINETEEN YEAR OLD.
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS MUCH
GREATER FOR BUSINESS THAN IT IS
TO HIRE A TWENTY NINE YEAR OLD
WITH THE FAMILY AND A HOUSE AND
A CAR PAYMENT X. ADDRESS --
STUDIES WILL SHOW THAT OUR ALLY
ON YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP --
WILL RETURN INVESTMENT BACK TO
THE EMPLOYER IN YEAR THREE OF AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE DOING THAT RIGHT NOW IN
COLORADO.
JUST A COUPLE MORE POINTS ON
THAT.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A LOT
GOING ON AN APPRENTICESHIP TODAY --
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
APPRENTICESHIP INITIATIVE THAT
HAS BEEN ROLLING UNDER THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE --
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK UNDER ET
P. -- WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK WORK WITH
LINK LEARNING IN DUAL CREDIT BUT
IT'S ALL VERY DESPERATE IT'S ALL
VERY ON CONNECTED WE DO NOT HAVE
A SYSTEM.
THAT REALLY ALLOWS HIGH SCHOOLS
AND INTO WORK TOGETHER TO MOVE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND TO WORK.
IF WE APPLY HE SWISS MODEL IN
CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW WE'RE NOT
SWITZERLAND --
WE RUN SOME NUMBERS CALIFORNIA
WOULD HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND APPRENTICES.
BUSINESSES WOULD INVEST ABOUT
EIGHTEEN POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE APPRENTICESHIP
MODEL.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WOULD EARN
TWENTY POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS --
SKEWS ME THE BUSINESSES WOULD
EARN TWENTY POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS BACK ON THEIR INVESTMENT.
YOUNG PEOPLE ASK ABOUT SEVENTEEN
BILLION IN CONSUMER SPENDING AND
THIS I THINK IS A CRITICAL THING
STUDENT DEBT WOULD BE REDUCED BY
ABOUT SIXTEEN BILLION
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO WHAT WE RECOMMEND.
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION IN PARTNERSHIP WITH --
OUR PARTNERS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE BOTH LOCALLY REGIONALLY
AND STATEWIDE.
ARE WORKING TO ADVANCE A YOUTH
POLICY INFRASTRUCTURE A YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP POLICY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
A COUPLE OF RECOMMENDATIONS
GOVERNANCE WE RECOMMEND.
THAT A GOVERNOR FACILITATED BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION LED BY EXPERTS
FROM BUSINESS AND EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
BE WELL VERSED IN THE MODERN
APPRENTICESHIP MODEL.
WE RECOMMEND POLICY ALIGNMENT BE
REALLY --
SCRUTINIZE SO WE CAN TRANSITION
FROM A SET OF PARALLEL A
COMPETING PROGRAMS. TO A SINGLE
WELL ARTICULATED SYSTEM AND THIS
WOULD INCLUDE CONDUCTING A
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS TO
DETERMINE THE CHANGES THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO FACILITATE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN HIGH SCHOOL WORKING.
THE ADDITION TO HIGH SCHOOL
DESIGN WAIT OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS TO MOVE OUR FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
OPPORTUNITY YOU INTO
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. TO
SECURE SUSTAINABLE FINANCING FOR
SECONDARY AND POST SECONDARY
INSTRUCTION BUILDING UPON THE
RECENT BUDGET TRAILER BILL --
POLICYMAKERS ADDRESS LAST YEAR
WE'RE THRILLED ABOUT THAT AND
THEN DESIGNING SUSTAINABLE
FINANCING MODEL FOR
INTERMEDIARIES.
WE WILL LOOK TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS TO
CREATE GUIDELINES FOR
STREAMLINED ONLINE REGISTRATION
PROCESS.
THAT IS THAT IS A SHAREABLE
REPOSITORY THAT INCLUDES A
SHAREABLE REPOSITORY OF
CURRICULA FOR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS.
WE RECOMMEND THAT WE WORK TODAY
TO CONTINUE THE WORK AROUND
EDUCATIONAL ALIGNMENT THAT
ALLOWS WILL DO ALL CREDIT
BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND ACTUALLY ALLOWS FOR CREDIT
ELECTIVE OR OTHERWISE FOR
WORKING.
LASTLY PREPARE AN OUT REACH
AWARENESS AND COMMUNICATIONS
CAMPAIGN.
THAT ENGAGES THE PUBLIC AROUND
THE IMPORTANCE OF WORK.
AND THE VALUE OF WORK OF A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS --
I JUST LOOK AT SOME FIGURES IN
199730% OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WORK TODAY 19% OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WORK.
PARENTS ALL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WANT THE
KIDS TO GO TO COLLEGE I'M NO
EXCEPTION --
BUT I THINK WHEN A YOUNG PERSON
SAYS MOM DAD I WANT TO WORK IN
THE REFINERIES WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SAY ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S HAVE AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM AND LASTLY THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM THAT WE
DEVELOPED IN CALIFORNIA MUST BE
PERMEABLE WHICH MEANS A YOUNG
PERSON WHEN THEY FINISH THEIR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
CAN AUTOMATICALLY ENTER INTO
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION --
WHEN THEY GRADUATE WITH THEIR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM A DEGREE
OR CERTIFICATE PROGRAM AND ALLOW
THEM ENTRANCE INTO THE CSU
SYSTEM?
THE FUTURE WORK IS HERE WE'VE
ALL HEARD ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
WORK.
AND FROM OUR MONEY.
WE NEED TO BE ARCHITECTS OF THE
FUTURE NOT VICTIMS OF THE FUTURE
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER LANDER I SAW.
IT SO THERE MAY BE QUESTIONS
AFTER THIS I CERTAINLY WANT TO
FOLLOW UP WITH ON A COUPLE
QUESTIONS BUT LET ME GO HEAD TO
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER --
MISS RUNNER SURE REEF --
RONA WORK FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
WHERE SHE SERVED AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH FOR THE
SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH
MANAGING ISSUES.
RELATED TO EDUCATION OF WORK
FORCE LABOR AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT POLICY
AS SHE NOW SERVES AS THE CO
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA AGE
COALITION WHICH IS A COALITION
OF BUSINESS LABOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
EDUCATION.
AND WORKFORCE ORGANIZATIONS
ENGAGED IN EDUCATION AND
ADVOCACY FOCUS ON CLOSING THE
SKILLS AND EQUITY GAP IN
CALIFORNIA.
GO HEAD AND BEGAN.
GOOD MORNING I'M RHONDA SHEAR
FROM CO DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA IT'S COALITION SO WE
DON'T DESPAIR COALITION IS AN
UNUSUAL COLLECTION OF PARTNERS
WHO.
RARELY AGREE ABOUT ANYTHING BUT
THEY WE THAT WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF CLOSING.
THOUGH THE SKILL GAP THE EQUITY
GAP.
IN CALIFORNIA AND MEETING THE
NEEDS OF BUSINESSES AND THEIR
WORK FORCE NEEDS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE.
WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE HIM GIVE YOU
A CALIFORNIA WE'RE NINE MEMBERS --
OTHER MEMBERS INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FED THE
CAREER LADDERS PROJECT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION.
THAT LOS ANGELES CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE POLICY LINK THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL AND YOU
NEED AS YOU S. WHICH IS THE
CURRENT NAME HE USED TO BE
NATIONAL COUNCIL RAZA WHICH
MIGHT BE MORE FAMILIAR WITH THE
CHANGE THEIR NAME.
SO WHAT WE DO IS WE ENGAGE IN
EDUCATION ADVOCACY AND COALITION
BUILDING AROUND WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING POLICY
AND INVESTMENTS TO MOVE PEOPLE
THEM.
CAREER PATHWAYS AND SUSTAIN A
MIDDLE CLASS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS --
IN THE WORLD IN THE AREA OF
EDUCATION WE DO POLICY MAKER
BRING THINGS AROUND KEY TOPICS.
WE WERE YOU KNOW WE DO RESEARCH
PAPERS ARE SHORT BRIEFING PAPERS --
WE WE SUPPORT BILLS AND
LEGISLATION SO IF YOU HAVE THAT
LEGISLATION IN THIS AREA COME TO
US BECAUSE WE WERE YOU KNOW WE
FEEL LIKE WE'RE THIS.
AMAZING COALITION OF UNLIKELY
PARTNERS THAT ADD YOU KNOW ED
VOICE TO JUST GOOD PUBLIC POLICY.
AND WE'RE ALSO ENGAGED IN
COALITION BUILDING --
AROUND THE STATE NOW YOU.
YOU'LL HEAR A LOT OF THE SAME
THINGS YOU HEARD FROM THE BURKE
OR CO PANELISTS HERE YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE SO WE'RE REALLY --
THAT WE WERE SAYING THE SAME
THING.
YOU KNOW --
NEARLY. 25% OF OUR WORK FORCE OF
FIVE MILLION PEOPLE MAKE LESS
THAN FOURTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
AND MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
WORKING.
NOT ONE JOB WITH MANY JOBS AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOUSING AND
OTHER EXPENSES THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE CALIFORNIA IT
CAN BE CONSIDERED THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATE IN.
YOU KNOW IN THE NATION ANY STATE
IN THE NATION.
AS I SAID MANY OF THEM ALL YOUR
WHOLE MULTIPLE JOBS SO THEY HAVE
VERY LITTLE TIME TO TO TO GO AND
GO BACK TO SCHOOL AND TO GET
TRAINING AND LIMITED OPPORTUNITY
TO GET THE SKILLS AND
CREDENTIALS TO MOVE UP.
A CAREER PIPELINE.
MANY MORE INDIVIDUALS WE HEARD
ABOUT THEM ESPECIALLY FROM C. WA
FACED A LOT OF BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT I MEAN THEY HAVE
BASICALLY WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
AND MATH SKILLS THEY HAVE
CRIMINAL RECORDS.
THEY HAVE FINANCIAL CONSTRAINTS
AND REALLY LIMITED EMPLOYMENT
EXPERIENCE OF MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO OBTAIN JOBS.
WE HEAR THAT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME BUSINESSES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE HAVE CRITICAL SHORTAGES OF
OF MIDDLE SKILLED WORKERS I MEAN
TO INDUSTRIES A PARTICULAR THAT
WE HEARD ABOUT EARLIER --
ARE THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY I
THINK WE ALSO THINK THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY AND AND
MANY OTHERS FACE THOSE
CONSTRAINTS SO WE HAVE.
PEOPLE WHO REALLY NEED. TO GET
INTO THE PIPELINE AND MOVE UP
THE PIPELINE AND EMPLOYERS WHO
REALLY ARE EXPERIENCING GAPS IN
THE WORKFORCE --
SO -- IT'S A
HUGE CHALLENGE FOR THE STATE
CANCEL.
WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW AS PART OF
OUR COALITION BUILDING EFFORTS
AS WE ARE --
CASH.
YESTERDAY AND TODAY WE ARE COULD
BE ANYONE I'M CALLING OUR FIRST
ANNUAL SKILLS FOR CALIFORNIA
SUMMIT.
WE HAD --
YESTERDAY WE HAD OVER THE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL WORK FORCE
BOARDS COMMUNITYCOLLEGE
ORGANIZATIONS.
ADVOCATES --
A FOLKS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
COMING TO TO SACRAMENTO TO TALK
ABOUT A SERIES OF POLICY ISSUES
THE TWO GENTLEMEN HERE AT THE
TABLE WHERE THEY ARE.
AND TODAY OVER SIXTY OF THOSE --
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE MEETING WITH
WITH FOLKS OVER IN THE CAPITAL
WE HAVE BEATING SET UP TO
ADVOCATE FIRST SERIES OF POLICY
ACTIONS THAT WE THINK WILL ADD
WILL CREATE BETTER PATHWAYS FOR
FOLKS.
AND GREATER --
PROSPERITY FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES SO I'M JUST GOING
TO QUICKLY TOUCH ON THE THREE
THINGS THAT THEY WILL BE
ADVOCATING FOR IS THE AS AS OUR
TEAMS OF OF FOLKS ABOUT THE DOWN
THE STATE MEET WITH --
PEOPLE MAYBE IN YOUR OFFICES I
HOPE -- TO
TALK ABOUT --
STRATEGIES ONE IS AND WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT IT ALREADY IT'S
ABOUT MAKING COLLEGE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE.
A RECENT STUDY BY TEAK IS WHICH
IS THE IS FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY --
CAME OUT WITH A LOOKED AT THE
COST OF COLLEGE ATTENDANCE AND
FOUND MUCH TO THE SURPRISE OF
MANY OF US.
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH THE
MOST EXPENSIVE WHEN YOU TAKE
WHEN YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T GET --
THEY DON'T GET EIGHT EIGHT
INSTITUTIONAL AID WHICH YOU GET
IT AT C. ISSUE WHEN YOU SEE SO.
EVEN THOUGH THE TUITION IS LOW
THE NET COST IS VERY EXPENSIVE
THERE'LL BE I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS MENTION THAT THERE WILL BE A
BILL --
AROUND FINANCIAL AID --
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
THE SENATE'S AND LEYVA THAT WILL
KIND OF CHANGE THE WAY --
THE WAY OVER THE AWARD LEVELS
AND WHO'S ELIGIBLE FOR FOR
BENEFITS WE THINK THAT THAT
EFFORT AND MANY OTHER EFFORTS
BUT THAT THAT THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE WILL BE CONSIDERING THIS
YEAR VERY IMPORTANT WE WE REALLY
BELIEVE IN WILL BE ADVOCATING
FOR WE THINKING HOW YOU
DISTRIBUTE.
A FINANCIAL AID TO STUDENTS
RECOGNIZING THAT TODAY'S COLLEGE
STUDENT IS.
IS -- THE
AVERAGE AGE IS TWENTY FIVE MANY
OF THEM ARE WORKING AND THIS IS
JUST A WHOLE NEW TYPICAL COLLEGE
STUDENT THAT WHAT WE THOUGHT OF
TWENTY YEARS AGO TEN YEARS AGO
OR EVEN FIVE YEARS AGO.
SO WE WILL BE SUPPORTING HAVE
HAD TO MAKE COLLEGE MORE
ACCESSIBLE.
THE SECOND ISSUE THAT WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT AS WE MEET WITH
FOLKS TODAY.
IS THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AROUND
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PATHWAYS
THAT ARE IN DEMAND AND
CREDENTIALS THAT ARE VALUED BY
EMPLOYERS.
AND SO THAT YOU KNOW THAT.
SIMPLE IT'S VERY COMPLICATED AB
ONE IS IT.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
THERE ARE SO MANY CREDENTIALS
THAT THERE'S SOME OF THEM
OFFERED BY PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
SOME OF THEM OFFERED BY PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS PRIDE AND SOME OF
THEM FOR IF THE FOR PROFIT
INDUSTRY.
SO.
WHAT'S OUT THERE WHICH ONES HAVE
VALUE WHERE WHERE WHAT DO
EMPLOYERS AND WITHIN CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES RECOGNIZED AS
VALUABLE SO THAT.
PEOPLE WHEN THEY'RE DECIDING
WHERE TO SPEND THEIR TIME AND
EFFORT AND MONEY TO GET THIS
ADDITIONAL SKILLED TRAINING KNOW
WHERE TO GO AND WHAT THE OUTCOME
OF THAT IS.
WE ALSO --
WILL BE SUPPORTING WE ALSO
BELIEVE YOU SAID YOU HEARD --
AS BOB TALK ABOUT I I KNOW YOU
BOB.
BOB TALK ABOUT APPRENTICESHIP WE
THINK -- AND
LEARN STRATEGIES OR OR KIND OF
REALLY THE ONE OF THE BEST WAYS
TO PREPARE AND TO A MOVE PEOPLE
ALONG A WORKFORCE PIPELINE WITH
THE BEAUTY.
THE BEAUTY OF EARN AND LEARN
STRATEGIES IS PEOPLE GETTING
PAID WHILE THEY'RE LEARNING IT'S
BECAUSE MOST OF THE MOST PEOPLE
WHO ARE MAKING FORTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR CAN'T LEAVE.
LEAVES --
THEIR JOB TO GO AND LEARN.
SO WE ARE BIG SUPPORTERS OF
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING AND I
I'D LIKE TO MENTION ALSO THAT.
THE VALUE OF WE ALSO THINK THE
VALUE AND THERE'S A GREAT VALUE
AND IN DEVELOPING THESE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITIES
THEY ARE PATHWAYS. FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND THEIR WAY
AND THERE'S ANOTHER STRATEGY
THAT CAN.
CAN REALLY DIVERSIFY THE WORK
FORCE BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE
MOVING PEOPLE WHO WHO HAVE NOT
TRADITIONALLY GONE INTO THESE
FIELDS.
INTO INTO IT A RANGE OF FIELDS.
AND FINALLY OUR THIRD THING THAT
WILL BE ADVOCATING FOR TODAY IS
THE CREATION OF A STATE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT
CREATE FOR YEARS ABOUT CREATING
A STATE LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
AND AND OR OR NETWORK.
OF SUPPORTERS REALLY BELIEVE
THERE'S MULTIPLE VALUE IN IN
DOING SO I MEAN YOU KNOW POP IN
RESEARCHERS WANTED AND AND A LOT
OF OTHER YOU KNOW I THINK POLICY
MAKERS WOULD LIKE A LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM.
SO THAT THEY CAN UNDERSTAND THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THAT --
THAT YOU'RE MAKING IN PROGRAMS
THAT AND AND I BOTH WORK FIRST
PROGRAMS AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
BUT THE PUBLIC THE PUBLIC NEEDS
TO HAVE ACCESS SO THAT THAT IS
STUDENT WHEN THEY'RE DECIDING TO
GO O A COMMUNITY COLLEGE WILL
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU KNOW
HAVE.
YOU KNOW WHERE TO GO WHAT
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO STUDIES --
OF THE OUT THE EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES ARE DIFFERENT PUBLIC --
PROGRAMS OF STUDY SO WE REALLY
ADVOCATING AS YOU DELIBERATE
OVER CREATING THIS LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM THAT YOU REALLY
THINK ABOUT THE AUDIENCE SUPPORT.
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
ACCESSIBLE IT'S TRANSPARENT.
AND ALSO THAT IT IS BROADER THAN
JUST THE TRADITIONAL EDUCATION
SYSTEM THAT IS REALLY.
A OF A DESIGN THAT HAS THE
CAPABILITY OF INTEGRATING
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS INTRUDE INTO
GRADING --
OTHER INTERVENTIONS WOULD YIELD
SO THAT YOU CAN LOOK AT HOW HOW
COME SIMPLY MEANT AND COMPLETION
OUTCOMES --
WORK WITH --
WITH.
EUROPE WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
LEAVING PRESENT I THANK YOU VERY
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE USE
DEVELOPING A SYSTEM LIKE THIS.
YOU CAN'T STAR YOU GET YOUR
PROBABLY START SMALL BUT YOU
HAVE TO DESIGN THIS WITH THE
CAPABILITY OF INTEGRATING A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
UNDERSTANDING THE
INTERRELATIONSHIP.
OF THE WIDE RANGE OF HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT
ULTIMATELY AFFECT US.
AS STUDENTS IN A PART OF
CALIFORNIANSOUTCOMES IN OUR
SOCIETY.
SO IN CLOSING I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT WHILE WE YOU KNOW WE WE'RE
BELIEVERS IN A HIGH QUALITY WORK
FIRST --
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM BUT THAT
ALONE CANNOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM
OF PROP POVERTY AND GROWING
INEQUALITY BUT WE THINK IT HAS A
MAJOR MAJOR ROLE TO PLAY.
AND WE WE REALLY APPLY TO YOU
FOR HAVING US YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY OF
THIS YEAR AND THE YEARS IN THE
FUTURE TO WORK WITH YOU.
AND MAKE IT A REALITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WELL I FIRST
WANT.
TO NOTE THAT SIDE TO THE PUBLIC
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
ROADMAP IS ON APPENDIX II THE
EDGE COALITION GOALS IS ON
APPENDIX K. SKILLS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S AGENDA IS ON
APPENDIX AL.
AND A FOR THE WITNESSES WE WOULD
LOVE IT IF YOU CAN SUBMIT OUR
PROPOSALS RECOMMENDATIONS ON
POLICY ACTIONS ARE TO OUR
COMMITTEE AFTER THIS HEARING --
IT'S I BELIEVE THIS IS A GREAT.
OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS I WILL START BY --
POSING A QUESTION TO YOU THAT WE
OFTEN HEAR ABOUT OUR COMMUNITIES
BACK HOME WITH WE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH.
OUR EMPLOYERS IN OUR REGION ARE
IN STAFF INSTITUTIONS EDUCATION
HOW CAN WE HOW CAN THE STATE
HELP TO TRANSACT TRANSCEND
HISTORIC DIVISIONS THAT EXIST --
IN CAREER TAG COLLEGE DEGREES AS
WELL AS THE EMPLOYER NEEDS IF IF
YOU CAN OFFER [inaudible]
IDEAS [inaudible]
WHAT COULD?
LET LET ME THINK ABOUT THAT
SAYING SO WHAT YOUR QUESTION IS
CAREER TECH.
WELL I THINK THAT WE HAVE REALLY
AND I THINK IS JIM HAS TALKED
ABOUT I MEAN ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IS THE POOR THAT THAT
WE HAVE TODAY.
WE HAVE TRADITIONALLY DESIGNED
OUR PROGRAMS.
I'D I WOULD YOUR FROM THE
EDUCATION PERSPECTIVE AND WE AGO
AND WE REALLY NEED TO GET MORE
EMPLOYER INPUT.
INTO KIND OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
HOWEVER.
EMPLOYERS THAT WE DEAL WITH SAY
THEY SITTING IT TOO MANY TABLES
YOU KNOW EVERY PROGRAM HAS AN
EMPLOYER VISOR GROUP.
AND AND THAT BECAUSE AND AND
SOMETIMES THE WRONG PEOPLE ARE
SITTING AT THE TABLE SO IF IT IS
A HUGE IT IS A HUGE CHALLENGE.
TO TEND TO INTERN TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ALIGNED TO WORKFORCE NEEDS --
BUT THERE ARE EFFORTS THERE ARE
EFFORTS TO TO BRING TOGETHER AND
CONSOLIDATE THIS BUT IT'S IT'S A
HUGE CHALLENGE I I WOULD.
JIM I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THAT HAVE.
YOUR OUT COMES INCENTIVES AND
INTERMEDIARIES.
K. --
OUTCOMES MEAN DON'T YOU'VE GOT
TO MEASURE SOMETHING THAT ALL OF
THEM ARE TRYING TO WORK TOGETHER
IF YOU LOOK AT THE STRONG WORK
FORCE OUTCOMES THEY LINED WITH
THE WHEEL OUTCOMES INTENTIONALLY.
AND THEY INCLUDED DID THEY GET A
JOB TO GET A JOB IN THE FIELD OF
STUDY INTO THE GET A RAISE SO
SITTING DOWN WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PRESIDENTS AND THEY SAID
WE'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
WE SAID THEN WHO ELSE YOU GET
THE MONEY.
AND ALL THE SAID THEY HAD A
STRONG INTEREST IN IT --
AND THEN IN TERMS OF IN SANTA
THAT PROGRAM AND THERE'S OTHERS
WERE YOU ACTUALLY CREATED IN THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM 17% OF
THOSE DOLLARS ARE ALLOCATED
BASED ON RESULTS.
AND IT AGAIN IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE COLLEGE PRESIDENTS THEY
ARE USING EVERY DIME TO IMPROVE
THEIR RESULTS BECAUSE THEY WANT
THEIR 17%.
AND INTERMEDIARIES ARE IT IS
ASSOCIATIONS THAT --
THAT LIKE IT'S COALITION AND
LIKE THE WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
BUT ALSO THE REGIONAL CIVIC
LEADERS EVERYONE OF OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERS IS ENGAGED IN WORKFORCE.
AND AS MISTER NEAL CAN TELL YOU
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
BRINGING TOGETHER THE SYSTEMS.
AND USING THEIR OWN POLITICAL
CAPITAL AT A SCALE WHERE THIS
MAKES A DIFFERENCE WHICH IS
COMMUNITY AND REGION IN ORDER
SAY LOOK WE'VE GOT THE NEED
WE'VE GOT THE DOLLARS WE'VE GOT
THE INCENTIVES WERE DRIVING
TOWARDS THE OUTCOMES WHAT DOES
IT TAKE.
YOU CAN'T ENGINEER IT FROM HERE
BUT YOU CAN CREATE THE STRUCTURE
AND WHICH STORE LEADERS AT A
REGIONAL COMMUNITY SCALE CAN
WORK WITH THESE ASSOCIATIONS TO
MOVE THE NEEDLE BUT YOU'VE GOT
TO BE DELIBERATE ABOUT IT.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD ONE MORE
THING TO THAT --
I SPENT THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS --
LAST WEEK WITH THE KRYCEK
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM THE STATE'S
AND WITH MANY SUPERINTENDENTS A
HIGH SCHOOL'S FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO WERE TALKING ABOUT.
HOW DO WE GET OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WORKPLACE READY?
AND THE MORE I START THINKING
ABOUT THE MORE I THOUGHT ABOUT
THE A THREE G. REQUIREMENTS AND
HOW.
HOW HIGH WE HOLD THEM UP --
WHEN WHEN MY STUDENTS REGISTER
FOR CLASSES EVERY YEAR THEY STOP
BY THEIR COUNSELORS DESK AND
THEY GET HANDED THE A THROUGH G.
REQUIREMENTS THEY DON'T GET
HANDED ANYTHING ABOUT C. T. E.
PROGRAMS?
PROGRAMS OF STUDY--
AND THE FUTURE THAT WORK AND
BRING TO THEM SO WE NEED TO
INGRAIN WORK IN HIGH SCHOOLS.
LASTLY I THINK WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THE THE COUNSELORS AND
HIGH SCHOOLS CALIFORNIA.
IS THE NATION'S LAST RATIO TO
COLLEGE CAREER COUNSELORS TO
STUDENTS NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN STUDENTS TO EVERY
CAREER COUNSELOR.
AND AND THEY JUST CAN'T KEEP UP
AND SO IF THERE IS A WAY THAT
THESE INTERMEDIARIES THESE
WORKFORCE BOARDS CAN GET INTO
THE HIGH SCHOOL AND PROVIDE
CAREER COUNSELING.
LIKE THEY DO IN OTHER STATES AND
SOUTH CAROLINA --
I THINK THAT WOULD BE FABULOUS
SO THOSE ARE JUST A COUPLE
THOUGHTS.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD A
THOUGHT ABOUT --
FUNDING AND AND I I THINK THAT
LOOKING AT OUTCOMES IS HUGE AND
LATE BUT IT'S COMPLICATED AND IF
WE REALLY WANT TO CLOSE EQUITY
GAPS YOU YOU HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL.
ABOUT HOW YOU LOOK AT THOSE
OUTCOMES SO THAT YOUR AND YOU SO
YOU'RE NOT DOING THE WRONG THING.
BECAUSE IT FUNDING IS TO TIED TO
TWO QUARTERS CERTAIN OUTCOMES
THAT MAYBE WE'RE NOT REACHING
THE PEOPLE WE NEED TO REACH TO
BREAK THE CYCLES OF POVERTY WE
HAVE IN THE STATE.
SO IT'S I I AGREE THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT OUTCOMES WE HAVE TO
HEAD THAT'S WHY WE DO NEED A
DATA SYSTEM WE HAVE BE VERY
CAREFUL BECAUSE WE'RE TRUMP WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS VERY
COMPLICATED.
VERY COMPARABLE.
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M AN
OPEN IT UP TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
FURTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR JUST A REAL QUICK --
COUPLE QUESTIONS ON FRIENDS
PROGRAMS AND TECHNICAL TRADES
AND AND HEARING THE GOVERNOR
TALK ABOUT UPSCALING WORKERS AND
RATHER THAN TRYING TO DISPLACE
THEM AT CERTAIN POINTS BUT AN
EARLY ON THROUGH --
HIGH SCHOOL --
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS THAT
ACCESSIBILITY --
FOR TRADES APPRENTICE PROGRAMS
TO BE PART OF THE DIALOGUE OR
TALKING ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
FUTURE OF GOING ON TO ATTAIN
YOUR COLLEGE DEGREES THAT'S
GREAT.
BUT THERE'S ALSO THOSE THE
PERCENTAGES DE NOT EVERYONE'S
GOING TO MAKE IT TO THAT POINT
AT THAT TIME IN THEIR LIFE RIGHT
SO LET'S GIVE HIM OPTIONS TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE EARLY.
EARLY ON IN HIGH SCHOOL WHEN
WE'RE OUT THERE HAVING THESE
DIFFERENT FAIRS THAT ARE THERE
THAT APPRENTICE PROGRAMS TRADE
PROGRAMS M. ARE WELCOMED ON
CAMPUS IS TO SHOW THAT THAT IS A
VIABLE TRADE. TO GET ENGAGED AND
WE WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THAT AND WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU TO THE CHAIR ON GATHER MORE
DATA AND TO LEND OUR SUPPORT TO
THAT.
ALSO WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT --
THE EDUCATION AND MOVING FORWARD
ON SOME OF THOSE THINGS I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN COLLEGE --
AND AFFORDABILITY THIS THERE IS
LOOKING AT THE PERCENTAGE OF
PART TIME STUDENTS THERE ARE
ALSO THERE.
PART TIME STUDENTS THAT NOW MAY
BE ON IN THEIR LIFE FIGURE THEY
NEED TO GET YOU KNOW INTO
EDUCATION SEE THOSE THINGS BUT
NOW THEY'RE PROVIDING FOR A
FAMILY THEY'RE WORKING THEY'RE
DOING THOSE THINGS.
SO LET'S NOT FORGET WHEN WE
START TO MOVE FORWARD TO BRING
THE TOPIC AROUND HIGHER
EDUCATION LET'S NOT FORGET THE
PART TIME STUDENTS THAT ARE
THERE TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD
THEIR LIVES ALSO.
IN THE BIGGER IT MAKES ITS THERE
THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT I WANTED TO TO RAISE
MINIATURE.
YEAH I HAVE SEVERAL FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS A HOW DO WE BEST
PREPARE OUR WORK FORCE --
FOR THINGS LIKE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WHICH A JIM
MENTIONED EARLIER ROBOTICS AND
AUTOMATION AS A HOLD.
CAN WE INCORPORATE THOSE --
THINGS INTO YOUR APPRENTICESHIPS --
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE WHAT IS SOME
OF THE CHANNELS THAT WE CAN DO
THAT WITH.
SO --
EXCELLENT QUESTION --
SO WOMEN CHILD SO.
THAT THE THE FOURTEEN WORKFORCE
REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR BROWN --
ORGANIZED THE FORTY FIVE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S IN
TO FOURTEEN REGIONS --
SEVERAL YEARS AGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE WORKING REGIONALLY
AS WELL ADULT SCHOOLS --
TO ARE BEGINNING TO PULL
INDUSTRY SECTORS TOGETHER AND I
THINK THE KEY IS YOU NEED TO
HAVE MORE THAN JUST ONE EMPLOYER
BUT YOU NEED TO HAVE A GROUP OF
INDUSTRIES --
WHETHER ITS MANUFACTURING THE OR
EVEN RETAIL GROCERY TO TALK
ABOUT THE CHANGES THAT THEY ARE
SEEING COMING DOWN THE PIPE --
JIM SAID IT EARLIER BUSINESSES
OF THE FIRST ONES TO RECOGNIZE
THE EFFECTS OF AUTOMATION THE
EFFECTS OF A AYE.
AND THEY'RE THE ONES WHO SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DICTATE THE
CURRICULUM THAT'S TAUGHT TO OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND ARE ADULTS ON
WHAT THEY NEED TO GET INTO THOSE
JOBS.
SO WE HAVE TO ENGAGE BUSINESS AT
A AT A MUCH DEEPER LEVEL AND
IT'S STARTING TO HAPPEN AROUND
SOME OF THE SECTOR INITIATIVES
AND ONE THING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN DO.
IS TO ADOPT A SECTOR STRATEGY
APPROACH --
AS A POLICY FRAMEWORK FOR DOING
WORKFORCE IN EDUCATION AND
REGION'S DROUGHT STATE.
I THINK I'D LIKE TO ADD I THINK
THAT EURO AS WE AS THESE
INDUSTRIES CHANGE.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DO JOBS BUT
THEY'LL BE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
OUT OF JOBS AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT A
STRATEGY OF HOW TO BRING.
A WORKFORCE TRAINING TO THE
EMPLOYER.
EMPLOYMENT SO THAT WE CAN UP
SKILL AND AND AND TRANSITION AS
MANY BETWEEN NOT EVERYONE WILL
BE.
CAPABLE OF THAT TRANSITION YEAH
WE HAVE I THINK MENTIONED
EARLIER WAS EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL PROGRAM.
THAT HAS RESOURCES FOR THAT BUT
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY THEY WE
GET THIS YEAR I THINK OR THIS
YEAR THERE'S ABOUT NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT GOES TO
RETRAINING --
AND ITS PERFORMANCE BASED AND
IT'S A GREAT PROGRAM BUT REALLY
AS WE'RE THINKING OF THE SCOPE
OF THIS OVER THE YEARS HAT YOUR
TO RETHINK OUR INVESTMENTS AND
THE WAYS IN WHICH WE TRY TO
LEVERAGE.
NOT JUST GOVERNMENTAL MONEY BUT
LEVERAGE IMPORTANT ASSONANCE IN
IN TANDEM TO RETRAIN THEIR
CURRENT WORK FORCE BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO BE IT'S GOING TO
BE A DO ALLEGE PROBLEM.
LAST YEAR WHEN WE DID A TWENTY
SIX MEETINGS SELECT CREATE AN
ONLINE COLLEGE WITH EMPLOYERS
AND COMMUNITY LEADERS.
THAN NOT MOST COMMON REFRAIN WAS
THEY SAW THIS IS VERY VALUABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO WHAT BOB
AND RUN IT JUST SAID.
THAT HAVE SOLD SOME OF THIS IS
WHAT CAN WE TEACH THAT THAT IS
ABOUT ENTREPRENEURIAL AND BILLY
TO LEARN AND ABILITY TO ADAPT.
SOME OF THAT IS CREATING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
PARTNERSHIP SO WE CAN REACT
QUICKLY.
YEAH IF I COULD JUST ADD ONE
MORE THING --
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT RUN A SAID.
HISTORICALLY A LOT OF THAT AND
WE CALLED INCUMBENT WORKER
TRAINING A LOT OF THAT INCOME
BUT WORKER TRAINING IS LOOKED ON
AS CORPORATE WELFARE YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE YOU KNOW.
SUPPORT BUSINESSES UPGRADING
THEIR OWN TALENT --
AND PEOPLE FEEL THAT THE
BUSINESSES SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DOING THAT HOWEVER I THINK
WE SEE THAT IF IF THAT IF IT'S
NOT A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESS WERE
LEFT WITH WHAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A HUGE
SEGMENT.
OF OUR POPULATION IS BEING LEFT
BEHIND.
CAN I ADD TO THAT I'D SAY THAT
ALSO HEALTHCARE IS ONE OF THE
HUGEST INDUSTRIES WHERE WE HAVE
WORKFORCE THESE ESPECIALLY WELL
PAYING MIDDLE SKILL WORKFORCE
THESE AND MOST OF HEALTHCARE.
DOESN'T PAY INTO THE APPOINTMENT
TRAINING FUND AND IS CAN IS NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR RESOURCES TO
UPGRADE THEIR THEIR WORKFORCE.
AND TO TRAIN THEIR WORKFORCE
ABOUT THE SECOND QUESTION THAT I
HAVE IS A WOULD YOU SAY THAT THE
MOST OF THE JOB GROVE --
IN CALIFORNIA IS IS WERE --
A LET'S SAY A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA SAID NEEDED OR TO YOUR
COLLEGE A COLLEGE HERE ADVANCE
SOMEBODY WITH THAT ADVANCED
DEGREE WHICH WHICH WOULD.
BILL WOULD BE CORRECT TO SAY
THAT --
WHICH LEVEL WOULD YOU
CHARACTERIZE THE MOST OF THE JOB
GROWTH IS SO YOU'RE TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE SUPPLY
SIDE OF THIS THE WORKER SUPPLY
SIDE AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU
FROM AS OPPOSED TO THE FOLKS
THAT ARE ON THE DEMAND SIDE OF
THAT AND AND WHAT.
I CAN SUGGEST TO YOU IS THAT IN
EVERYONE OF OUR REGIONS THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR BOTH AND AND I WOULD
ADD JUST. FOR MY OWN PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE IS I THINK THAT
THERE'S A REAL OF WHAT I SEE IS
A REAL DEMAND.
FOR BOTH THE CREDENTIAL PEACE
YOUR THE TWO YEAR OR THE
CERTIFICATE.
AND THE MORE ADVANCED THE FOUR
YEAR DEGREE YOU KNOW AS A MOTHER
I'LL JUST SAY THAT THE FOUR YEAR
DEGREE.
YOU KNOW I'VE SEEN AS HAVING
DIMINISHING VALUE YOU'RE EITHER
GOING TO GET SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY TARGETED AND THEN DEMAND
WITH IT YOU KNOW BUT AND
RECOGNIZED BY EMPLOYERS VALUABLE
OR YOU'RE GOING ON FOR MORE THAN
FOUR YEARS.
AND AND MANY OF THE CAREER
CENTER'S THEIR BUSINESS
ENGAGEMENT TEAMS ARE NOW TRYING.
TO TO RECOMMEND THE BUSINESSES
THAT VARIANCE IN LIEU OF AFTER
YOU KNOW FOR YOUR DEGREE IS
REQUIRED BUT WILL TAKE
EXPERIENCE IN LIEU OF THE FOUR
YEAR DEGREE --
AS A WAY TO GIVE EMPLOYERS MORE
OPTIONS FOR FOLKS THAT MAY HAVE
A TWO YEAR DEGREE.
AND THE EXPERIENCE WHO COULD BE
JUST AS VALUABLE OF NOT MORE
THAN SOMEBODY COMING RIGHT OUT
OF COLLEGE AT THE FOR YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO I DO WANT TO JUST FOLLOW UP
ON SOME OF THE WORK FORCE --
IN CALIFORNIA WHAT DO YOU
BELIEVE.
THAT OUR OUR GREATEST STRENGTH
IS WHEN IT COMES TO WORK FORCE.
OUR DIVERSITY WE HAVE AYE BE
SOMETIMES SOME PEOPLE SEE IS
THAT CHALLENGE I WE SEE IT IS A
TREMENDOUS STRENGTH FOR
CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO CAPITALIZE ON IT
BUILD ON IT.
AND YOU KNOW AND AN INTEGRATED
INTO OUR FUTURE IN IN REAL
POSITIVE WAYS YES.
DIVERSITY AND IS YOUR CIVIC
EXAMPLE OF HOW JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF THAT IS THE WORK SOME WORK
THAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AROUND MAKE THE NEXUS BETWEEN
VERY SMALL BUSINESS ESPECIALLY
ETHNIC CAM AND IMMIGRANT
BUSINESSES AND GLOBAL TRADE.
BECAUSE THE INTERNET ALLOWS ALL
OF THEM TO TO TO ENGAGE IN THAT
ENTIRE MARKET SO --
IT'S THIS LONG BEEN OUR STRENGTH.
AND WE'RE FINDING NEW WAYS FOR
TO BE A STRENGTH EVEN IN A
CHANGING AND GLOBALLY MARKETED
WORLD.
YEAH I WOULD ECHO THAT.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'D I CERTAINLY WOULD LOVE TO
CONTINUE ASKING YOU QUESTIONS I
PERSONALLY I KNOW THAT I WILL BE
REACHING OUT. TO EACH OF YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
I THINK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU DO FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
MEMBERS THE NEXT PANEL THERE'S
NO FORMAL PRESENTATION THIS IS
ACTUALLY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
TO JUST DIVE A LITTLE DEEPER AND
TO MAYBE DISCUSS POINTS ON HOW
TO BUILD A COMPETITIVE INCLUSIVE
ECONOMY --
EACH OF OUR NEXT SPEAKERS
REPRESENTS GROUP GROUP INCLUDING
SMALL BUSINESS THE PROFESSIONAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPER AND A
MANUFACTURER OR GOALS TO ASK --
EACH WITNESS SHORE AND FOCUS
QUESTIONS IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
TOP TRENDS.
A POSSIBLE NEXT STEPS TOWARDS
SUPPORTING ECONOMIC INDEPENDENCE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IF WE CAN
HAVE OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS JOIN US.
WE ARE PLEASED TO WELCOME SCOTT.
HOWARD SHOULD PRESIDENT OF CAL
INSURANCE IN ASSOCIATES INC.
PAUL GRAY NEO PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP.
AND NICOLE RICE POLICY DIRECTOR
WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
UNITS OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING'S AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION HOW WELCOME EACH.
OF OUR PANELISTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US TODAY.
AT THIS MOMENT I LIKE TO OFER
EACH OF YOU AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO WRITE A BRIEF INTRODUCTION OF
THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND WE
COULD TURN IT OVER FOUR SEVEN Q.
AND A GREAT GUY.
AT YOUR CERVANTES MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
ON BEHALF OF PETER VIEGAS THE
CHAIR OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP AND OUR OUR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY --
I KIND OF WANT TO BE THE COLOR
COME OF A REGIONAL --
FOCUS ON SOME OF THE THE FAX AND
THE ISSUES THAT YOU'VE HEARD
THIS MORNING.
AND I WOULD ALSO SAY --
A REGIONAL REPRESENTATIVE
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IS
A CON IS AN ECONOMY OF REGIONS
AND THE MORE THAT WE CAN CREATE
POLICY --
THAT REFLECTS THAT I THINK THE
BETTER WILL BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
THE REAL CHALLENGES THAT AFFECT.
THE STATE THE COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW IN TODAY'S
ECONOMIC --
MILIEU.
MY MEMBERS ARE THE LARGER
EMPLOYERS OF THE INLAND EMPIRE --
THE INLAND EMPIRE IS TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND SQUARE MILES --
SABATINO COUNTY THE SIZE OF
ISRAEL --
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THE SIZE OF NEW
JERSEY --
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION PEOPLE
ACCORDING TO THE U. S.
CONFERENCE OF MAYORS ON OUR WAY
TO SIX POINT.
FIVE BY --
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE TWENTY FORTY
BUT A REGION'S OF OVER MILLION
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THE LOWEST
BACCALAUREATE ATTAINMENT IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND SO THAT IS A LIMITING FACTOR --
ON THE TYPE OF INDUSTRY THAT WE
CAN WE CAN HALF --
WE ARE --
THEREFORE VERY --
BLUE COLLAR DEPENDENT REGION --
MANUFACTURING --
GOODS MOVEMENT AND LOGISTICS THE
BLUE COLLAR JOBS AND HEALTH CARE.
ARE REALLY --
THE FOCUS OF OUR ORGANIZATION.
AND WE DO PUBLIC POLICY IN
WASHINGTON AND HERE FOR OUR
MEMBERS --
BUT WE'RE ALSO HEAVILY INVOLVED
IN THIS ISSUE OF EDUCATION AND
WORK FORCE --
BECAUSE IT MATTERS TO MY MEMBERS
AND SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN --
GET THIS RIGHT I THINK --
THE BETTER WE WILL BE --
GROWTH AS OUR REGION --
I TALKED ABOUT THE THE THE
PRESSURE OF A LOW BACCALAUREATE
ATTAINMENT --
OF REGIONS IN THE UNITED STATES
THE INLAND EMPIRE HAS THE FOURTH
LARGEST LATINO POPULATION LOS
ANGELES NEW YORK HOUSTON AND THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
AND YET DISPROPORTIONATELY
LATINOS ARE AFFECTED BY THAT --
BACCALAUREATE ATTAINMENT ISSUE
AND IF YOU'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT EQUITY ISSUES --
DISPROPORTIONATELY NOT A LOT OF
FOCUS BEING PUT ON THAT HALF OF
OUR POPULATION TWO POINT TWO
MILLION.
AND ALL OF ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
IMPORTANT --
BUT I REALLY DO THINK THAT AS
CALIFORNIA'S LATINO POPULATION
GROWS WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT WE
ARE FINDING WAYS THAT --
WE CAN --
CHANGE --
THE RESULTS THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
GETTING AN EDUCATION WORKFORCE
AND AND MY BUSINESS MEMBERS WILL
TELL YOU WHEN THEY LOOK AT THEIR
LEADERSHIP BENCH --
THEY KNOW THAT THE THAT --
MINORITIES ARE.
COUPLE OF THINGS TWO THINGS FROM
THE SECOND TO PRESENTATION THAT
YOU SAW --
CALLED OUT --
THE LOGISTICS INDUSTRIES --
THE GOODS MOVE IN INDUSTRY AS
GREATER LOS ANGELES --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES YOU KNOW.
HOW?
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AFFECTS THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
AND SO AS AS MISTER MAYOR IS
TALKING ABOUT THE FOCUS ON
REGIONS --
JUST IN THAT PRESENTATION AND NO
DISRESPECT OKAY --
BUT WE HAVE TO DIG DEEPER INTO
GREATER LOS ANGELES IS TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
DEPENDING HOW YOU YOU --
LAID OUT --
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S --
POPULATION LIVE SOUTH OF THE TWO
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE POLICY WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT OF THESE
ISSUES WE HAVE TO GET TO I THINK
A MORE GRANULAR LEVEL --
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO FIND THE SOLUTIONS.
ON THE ISSUE OF EMPLOYER MEANING
GAUGE MEANT EVERYTHING THAT THE
LAST PANEL SAID.
EMPLOYERS BEING ASKED TO ATTEND
TOO MANY MEETINGS NOT GETTING
THE OUTCOMES THAT THEY WANT --
THERE ARE BETTER WAYS TO DO THIS
AND WE NEED TO WE NEED TO LOOK
AT OTHER MODELS OF HOW WE
REGIONAL LIVES --
AT THAT THE THAT THE SUBREGION
LEVEL -- BUT
ALSO MAYBE BREAKING THE STATE
OFTEN TO YOU KNOW ELEVEN
DIFFERENT REGIONS SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE THESE.
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
LAST A PIECE AT ALL BRING UP IS --
OF ALL THOSE PRESSURES ON THE
INLAND EMPIRE THE ONE THAT KEEPS
ME UP AT NIGHT IS THE RISE OF
THE ROBOTS.
AND IT IS AUTOMATION.
SO --
ACCORDING TO WORK DONE OUT OF
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS --
65% OF OUR CURRENT JOBS COULD BE
AUTOMATED AWAY BY --
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTE ANOTHER SURVEY THAT
SAID -- 47%
OF OUR JOBS DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO CREATE NEW JOBS WE
ARE GOING TO CREATE NEW JOBS.
BUT WE NEED TO BE HYPER.
VIGILANT --
WEEK WE CANNOT WAIT --
THE EXAMPLE I USE YESTERDAY TO
TALK IS WHEN'S THE LAST TIME ANY
OF US WALKED INTO THE BANK TO
GET MONEY RIGHT. FOR GENERATION
NOW WE'VE BEEN GOING TO THE ATM
THAT WAS THE CUTTING EDGE OF
AUTOMATION.
AND WE SEE IT LITTLE BY LITTLE --
AND IT'S MEANT TO MAKE OUR LIVES
EASIER OKAY IT'S MEANT TO MAKE
OUR LIVES EASIER.
BUT IT DOES HAVE --
CONSEQUENCES FOR EMPLOYMENT --
THIS IS GREAT STATE AND IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL STATE AND WE HAVE SO
MANY ADVANTAGES BUT WE NEED TO
WORK MUCH CLOSER TOGETHER --
ON THESE BIG ISSUES THANK YOU
MISTER WE CAN MOVE --
TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF PHONE COMMENTS AS WELL
OPENING INTRODUCTION A CHORUS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
BY INTRODUCTION THIS NICOLE RICE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO BE
THE STATE WIDE TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE INTERESTS.
OF CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY THOUSAND
PLUS A MANUFACTURING COMPANIES
AND ARE ONE POINT THREE MILLION --
MANUFACTURING WORKERS --
ALSO JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU --
MY BACKGROUND IN THIS ISSUE AREA
WE CURRENTLY CO CHAIR --
A COALITION --
ALONG WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES THAT FOCUSES ON K.
THROUGH --
TWELVE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CTV
POLICIES CALLED THE GET REAL A
COALITION REELS AN ACRONYM THAT
SPENT STANDS FOR RELEVANCE IN
EDUCATION AND LEARNING --
ALSO A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THE AGILE
COALITION THAT WAS --
PRESENTED AND REPRESENTED --
BY ROSE SHERIFF ON THE PREVIOUS
PANEL --
ALSO HAVE BEEN A MEMBER FORCE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL WORKING
WITH -- FAN
OF VICE CHANCELLOR BONTA ON
QUINLIVAN TO ESTABLISH THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO SHORE UP
THERE CRITIC EDUCATION PROGRAMS
AND OFFERINGS.
AND FINALLY --
A PROUD MEMBER OF THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD --
WORKING WITH SOME VERY
OUTSTANDING PEOPLE AS AN
APPOINTEE OF GOVERNOR BROWN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FROM THE
STATE'S WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SYSTEM I LOOK FOR TO YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THINK HERE.
WELCOME.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY --
I AM THE PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER.
OF SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA AND
I ALSO.
AGENCY FOR ABOUT FORTY FORTY
YEARS OR SO SO I HAVE.
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW WHAT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
FOR ALL MY LIFE --
JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND SPOKE
WITH ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
ALWAYS GET ASKED IS WITH THE
SMALL BUSINESS.
AND IT DOES VERY DEPENDING ON
WHO YOU'RE ASKING.
THE SB A USES ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES.
CALIFORNIA USES ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND THEN YOU'LL UP TALK TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT MICRO BUSINESSES
AND THAT'S LESS THAN TEN
EMPLOYEES. FOR THE MOST PART --
WE LOOK AT WITH.
LESS THAN A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
WHO RECOGNIZE WITHIN EMPLOYEES
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
TEN FORTY FOUR AT A HUNDRED
EMPLOYEE --
FOR THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
LOOTING SOUL WRITERS.
PROXIMALLY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION --
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA --
SO.
AND WE MAKE UP ABOUT 50% OF THE
A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN 50% OF
THE EMPLOYMENT CALIFORNIA WORKS
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND AND
WHAT I'M TALKING HERE I'M
TALKING HUNDRED EMPLOYEES --
AS A DEFINITION.
AS AN ORGANIZATION WE FOCUS ON
WHAT I CALL THE GLOBAL ISSUES
THAT AFFECT ALL SMOKERS.
WE DO AN ANNUAL SURVEY
RETIREMENT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHAT ARE
THE ISSUES THAT --
ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO SMALL
BUSINESS AND SOME OF WHICH WE
CAN HAVE AN IMPACT ON SO WE
WHICH WE CAN'T.
BUT EVERY YEAR THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE HAS BEEN AFFORDABILITY AND
AVAILABILITY OF HEALTH INSURANCE --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE THAT'S
BEEN THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE DOES
HIS HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED.
WHAT'S ALSO INTERESTING THOUGH
IS WE LOOKED.
AT A WE GIVE A A LIST OF ISSUES
AND WHAT I THOUGHT REALLY
INTERESTING AS FAR AS SMALL
BUSINESSES STORES ISSUES.
IS -- THE
OTHER HOUSING COSTS WITH.
A HUGE HUGE ECONOMY THOSE KIND
OF THINGS.
BUT HIGH UP ON THE LIST.
QUALITY OF PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESS YOU DON'T THINK OF THAT
THAT IS A MAJOR ISSUE FOR FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES --
AND THAT'S OUR WORKFORCE SO.
THAT IS CRITICAL.
THE OTHER THE OTHER ISSUE THAT
COMES UP IS IMAGES MOVE THE
MICROPHONE A LITTLE CLOSER TO
SAID THAT I WAS I HAVE
DIFFICULTY HEARING MONNING CARE.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE --
IS VERY VERY HIGH ON THE
IMPORTANCE FOR SMALL BUSINESS
GETTING YOUR GOODS TO AND FROM --
TO AND FROM YOUR CUSTOMERS --
VERY HIGH THE ONES YOU'D
NORMALLY THINK OF IS --
REGULATIONS TAXATION THOSE CAN
MAKE REGULATIONS COMES UP WITH A
VERY -- VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IMPACTS THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS AS AN
ORGANIZATION.
WE TRY TO FOCUS --
ON THOSE ISSUES OF ACCESS TO
CAPITAL IS SIX SIGNIFICANT ISSUE --
START UP CAPITAL VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE SO WE WE GET HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN HIM BACK --
WE'VE THIS YEAR OR FOCUSING --
ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES BUT REALLY
QUICK.
FOCUSING ON ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
AND THERE'S A COUPLE OF BILLS --
FOR FORTY SEVEN WHICH WILL --
BASICALLY PUT MONEY IN THE
GOVERNOR GO GO BIZ PROGRAM --
WHICH WE THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WHICH WILL PROVIDE
CAPITALS SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND THEN WE ARE ALSO VERY
INVOLVED IN --
CROWD FUNDING.
WHICH IS A NEW SOURCE FOR SMALL
MIRACLES ON NEW BUT WE WE THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES --
FOR ACCESS TO CAPITAL FOR SMALL
BUSINESS WE HAVE A BILL --
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE WHICH IS --
ACCESS TO CAPITAL BUILDING THE
WERE THEY WERE FOCUSING ON ONE
OF THE THINGS JUST TO JUST.
TO GENERAL COMMENTS.
IS IS A HERE.
AND THIS IS WHAT I HEAR FROM
SMALL BUSINESSES AND IT TO A
LARGE DEGREE MAY BE OUR FAULT
WERE WORKING.
MOST OF US AND IT'S TO GET
INVOLVED IN ISSUES THE TAKE AWAY
FROM OUR FOR MORE JOBS BUT BUT
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE BEEN PUT.
AND HAVING A SEAT AT THE TABLE --
IS IS REALLYIMPORTANT AS AS ARE
PUTTING TOGETHER --
PUTTING TOGETHER OUTREACH TO THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO SMALL BUSINESS HAVE
SEATED ABLE.
AND BE ABLE TO GIVE GIVE THEIR
INPUT BECAUSE THEY COME IN A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE FAN.
MAJOR EMPLOYERS --
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS THOSE
KIND OF THINGS --
AND AND THAT'S A MAJOR ISSUE FOR
SMOKERS.
THANK YOU AND AND YOU KNOW I
FIND I JUST YOU SPOKE ABOUT
REGULATION AND SO.
IN YOUR POINT OF VIEW WHAT STEPS
CAN THE STATE TAKE TO MAKE
REGULATION SMARTER FOR THE REAL
REALITIES THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
FACE AND I KNOW THAT WE PROBABLY
ALL HAD DIFFERENT DISCUSSIONS
WITH OUR SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES BACK IN OUR HOME
DISTRICTS BUT WANTED TO POSE
THAT QUESTION AND AND SEE.
IF YOU COULD PROVIDE SOLUTIONS
COMMENTS ON THAT.
WELL THE PROBLEM.
THAT SMALL BUSINESS SPACES
THERE'S A WHOLE LOTTA
REGULATIONS A WHOLE WATER PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS.
AND IN A LOT OF CASES.
REGULATIONS ARE INTEGRATED --
WHAT THE STATE HAS WITH WHAT
LOCAL --
WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS IN THE
REGULATIONS THEY PLACE ON SMALL
BUSINESS AND?
A LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES DON'T
EVEN UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
REGULATIONS ARE COMING FROM THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHETHER IT'S
COMING FROM THE STATE OR WHETHER
IT'S COMING.
LOCALLY.
THEY JUST KNOW REGULATIONS ARE
PROBLEM AND AND PERMITTING IS A
PROBLEM AND IN SOME CASES THERE
IS NOT DISCUSSION --
BETWEEN THE VARIOUS ENTITIES.
SO THE REGULATIONS ON A LOCAL
BASIS ON INTEGRATED WITH WHAT'S
ON A STATE BASIS.
AND THEY'RE NOT TALKING TO EACH
OTHER SO THAT IS --
THAT IS A MAJOR PROBLEM THE
OTHER THE OTHER THING IS THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY OF THEM.
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
BE HELPFUL AND I KNOW --
THIS IS BEING DONE TO SOME
DEGREE -- IN
IN VARIOUS ENTITIES BUT LOOKING
AT THE REGULATIONS THAT ARE OUT
OUT THERE IN STREAMLINING THEM
GETTING RID OF THE ONES THAT ARE --
NOT APPLE ICAL DUPLICATIONS
THOSE KIND OF THINGS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO --
MANY MIGHT NOT REALIZE THAT 64%
OF MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE ACTUALLY.
LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES.
IN OUR INDUSTRY AND THEY MAKE UP
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND RELY ON OUR
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED OR LARGER
MANUFACTURERS --
FOR THEIR LIVELIHOOD --
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS SCOTT
WAS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT --
ABOUT VARIOUS DIFFERENT
REGULATIONS COMING FROM VARIOUS
GOVERNMENT SOURCES AND SMALL
COMPANIES HAVING CHALLENGES.
TRYING TO KEEP UP WITH THAT LET
ALONE ABOUT COMPLIANCE THEY
DON'T HAVE BIG H. R. DEPARTMENT
OR MAYBE EVEN AN HR PERSON IT
MIGHT JUST BE THE OWNER
THEMSELVES TRYING.
TO KEEP TRACK OF EVERYTHING FROM
THE LOCAL LEVEL ALL THE WAY TO
THE STATE AND EVEN THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS IS
DEFINITELY TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S COMPLY THAT NOT
COMPLIANCE I'M SORRY BUT THERE
IS COORDINATION.
BETWEEN THOSE REGULATIONS THAT
THEY'RE NOT CONFLICTING OR
CREATING SOME CHALLENGES --
WITH COMPLIANCE FOR THOSE --
THOSE PRIORITIES AND POLICY
INITIATIVES BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT BECAUSE THE SMALL
MANUFACTURERS ARE SMALL
COMPANIES DON'T HAVE THESE H. R.
PROFESSIONALS ARE DEPARTMENT.
THAT THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEM TO CURE VERY MINOR
REGULATIONS THAT MIGHT BE PAPER
VIOLATIONS OR YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT ISN'T NECESSARILY
THREATENING THE HATE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THEIR EMPLOYEES WAR OR
THE WORK FORCE OR OR THEIR THEIR
CONSUMERS OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE.
YOUR WHERE IT IS REASON
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
HELPFUL IN ADDITION TO THAT
THERE IS THE STATE HAS --
ENACTED A REVIEW OF REGULATION
TO DETERMINE --
ITS ECONOMIC IMPACT WE'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT REVIEWED SO THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT ECONOMIC AND NON
ECONOMIC IMPACTS BECAUSE FOR THE
SMALLER GUYS.
THE WHAT THE REGULATIONS WHAT
THE PURPOSE IS AND THEIR THEIR
OUTCOME AND THEIR IMPACT IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
COMPANIES WHO ARE RIGHT THERE ON
THE ON THE TAP.
OF EITHER PROSPERITY OR HAVING
TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS SO MAKING
SURE THAT THE REGULATIONS TARGET
IT IT MAKES SENSE THAT DOESN'T
HAVE AN OVER REACHING OVER OVER
BURDENSOME IMPACT. TO REALLY YOU
KNOW TO THREATEN THE FINANCIAL
VIABILITY OF THE SMALL COMPANIES
IS IMPORTANT TO BY LOOKING AT
THE REGULATION IMPACTS TO THE
ECONOMY.
BOTH SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM.
THANK YOU MISTRESS.
SO YOU KNOW WE STRIVE TO BE A
TRIPLE BOTTOM LINE ORGANIZATION --
THE ENVIRONMENT THE ECONOMY AND
AN EQUITY.
I THINK --
TO PUT YOU KNOW.
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA --
IS A REGULATORY BOARD.
EFFECTS ON THE ECONOMY THEY
DON'T LOOK AT THE EFFECTS
BECAUSE OF YOU AFFECT THE
ECONOMY --
THE EIGHT NATURAL COMES YOU'RE
GONNA FACT EQUITY AND SO.
AN EXAMPLE THERE I THINK OF HOW
THEN DO WE LOOK AT THE WHEN
WE'RE DEALING WITH REGULATION
HOW DO WE TAKE THOSE INTO
CONSIDERATION AND I THINK THE
MORE --
OVERSIGHT THE MORE QUESTIONS
THAT ARE ASKED ABOUT WELL WHAT
IS THAT ACTUALLY GOING TO DO
DOWN THE ROAD --
I THINK SOMETIMES THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S MISSION WHEN YOU DEAL
WITH SINGLE FOCUSED AGENCIES.
THANK YOU MICHIGAN AREA.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
BOB DO WE KNOW HOW MANY OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND CALIFORNIA
ARE SELF EMPLOYED --
IN TERMS OF PERCENTAGE OR
OTHERWISE [inaudible]
WELL I'VE.
FIRST OF ALL TO FIND SELF
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYED --
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT.
THE THEIR SELF EMPLOYED WITH NO
EMPLOYEES AND THAT'S WHAT MOST
PEOPLE THINK THAT'S USUALLY HOW
IT'S DEFINED RIGHT YEAH YEAH.
YOU CAN BE A SELF EMPLOYED IS
CORRECT SOLE PROPRIETOR I USE.
FOR CORRECT RIDER WITH EMPLOYEES
PRESS. FOR FOR THE MOST PART --
THE NUMBERS ARE.
I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY THE NUMBER
BUT THE VAST MAJORITY.
OF BUSINESSES ARE LESS THAN FIVE
EMPLOYEES --
PROBABLY IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION.
OF THE OF THE THREE AND A HALF
MILLION SO TO THE LARGE MAJORITY
ARE. TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION.
COMPANIES ARE LESS AND FIVE
EMPLOYEES.
THANKS.
MISTER ROBERTS DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION JUST REAL.
QUICK MADAM CHAIR I JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WITH YOURSELF AND AND
MISTER BENNY OF THAT WE'VE.
START LOOKING AT WITH --
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
GOING ON THERE WITH THEM
GENERATION GOLF TEAMING UP WITH --
THE BUSINESSES IN THE AREA IN
THAT PARTICULAR --
PROGRAM PILOT PROGRAM I WORKED
WITH THEM HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
FROM SAN REGIONAL HIGH SCHOOL
ARE SEVERAL CITY UNIFIED.
AND EARLY HEAD REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER AND MEDICAL TRANSPORT
INITIAL BRINGING --
STUDENTS TOGETHER NOT WAITING
UNTIL FURTHER ROM BUT IN THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL --
IN BRINGING THEM FORWARD TO
EXPOSE THEM TO THE PIPELINE OF
OF THE WORK FORCE ITSELF.
AND THE AT THAT PILOT PROGRAM WE
HAD THIRTY ABOUT THIRTY STUDENTS
THAT WERE INVOLVED IN THAT.
AND THEY WENT THROUGH THE HIGH
SCHOOL BUT THEY ALSO WENT TO THE
COMMUNICABLE AJ AND AND BUILT
THE CREDITS UP THERE.
AND UPON GRADUATION THE SEVERAL
OF THEM WERE OFFERED A FULL TIME
POSITION WITHIN THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE THERE SO THESE TYPES OF
THINGS ARE GOING ON THE
MANUFACTURING ASPECT WITHIN THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
IS SOMETHING THAT'S ALSO A LARGE
SECTOR OF OF GROWTH IT'S IN OUR
AREA AND LOOKING AT THOSE AREAS
THAT ARE THERE AND BILLION TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE MAKING SURE
THAT THE ROADS IN THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS.
ARE ALL THEIR SO THAT THIS
PRESENTATION IN THIS THIS
HEARING --
OUT OF CHAIRS BEEN REALLY GREAT
AND WELL ROUNDED AS FAR AS
TOUCHING ALL THE DIFFERENT
TOPICS.
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AS FAR
AS FOR BUT SEEN THE SUCCESS
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE I THINK WE NEED TO
SHOW THAT STORY.
A LITTLE BIT MORE SO WHEN WE DO
TALK ABOUT.
AREAS IN GREATER LOS ANGELES AND
THOSE ARE ALL GREAT BUT LET'S
NOT FORGET THAT THERE'S REGION'S
RIGHT REGIONAL GOALS AND NEED TO
BE DONE.
WE COULD SET UP A STRUCTURE THAT
COULD FIT EACH REGION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO HIGHLIGHT
THOSE GOALS THAT ARE THERE JUST
WANT THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION FOR YOUR DISCUSSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT ON YOU KNOW
I'M I'M THE FATHER OF THE SEVEN
YEAR OLD.
AND THIS ISSUE OF SKILLS
DEVELOPMENT I KNOW WHAT SHE CAN
DO AND LEARN ON THE IPAD --
HER MOTHER HAS A PHD --
I'VE GOT TO ADVANCED DEGREES IN
THEOLOGY OKAY --
IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE AGAINST
HIGHER ED --
BUT I HAVE TO TRY AND BE THE
BEST DAD I CAN'T AND MAKE SURE
THAT SHE'S GOING TO HAVE --
SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE AND SO
THIS ISSUE OF HOW WE BILLET%
SKILLS --
EXPERIENCE BE A ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE TEAM WORK ALL OF
THAT HAS TO START VERY YOUNG SO --
AND I I COULDN'T AGREE MORE
ABOUT THE FOCUS ON REGION'S
APPROACH.
AND I DO WANT TO ADD ONS THAT
THERE THERE HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL REGIONAL INITIATIVES
THAT WE'VE READ A BALLOTS AND
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE BUILD ON THAT
AND I LEARN MORE ABOUT WHAT
OTHER REGIONS ARE DOING THAT ARE
WORKING.
I JUST TALKING ABOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN TALKING ABOUT THE I.
E. OPPORTUNITIES ARE.
MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS AS I
ALWAYS SHARE WITH FOLKS THEY
HAVE TO THE COMMUTE INTO OUR
COASTAL COMMUNITIES FOR WORK --
FOR HIGH SKILLED WHAT WE'RE
LOSING IS THIS BRAIN DRAIN --
THAT WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT WE HAVE
GREAT INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION SURROUNDING THE INLAND
EMPIRE FROM SAMBAR DINO COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND MANY OF THESE RECENT COLLEGE
GRADUATES ARE LEAVING FOR BETTER
JOBS IN OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
NOW.
WE ALSO HAVE THE ISSUE OF
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT AS YOU
MENTIONED IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS MISTER GREMIO YOU KNOW
HOW WHAT DO YOU SEE.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TRADE
TRACKS --
THESE HIGH SKILLED EMPLOYERS TO
OUR REGION.
YOU WHAT IS IT THAT WE NEED TO
PROPOSE --
IN ORDER TO GET THESE HIGH
SKILLED JOBS IN THE AREAS --
SUCH AS SAMBAR DO NO COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY FOR AFTER THE
RISE OF THE ROBOTS THIS IS THE
SECOND.
ONE THE KEEPS ME UP AND IT'S THE
CHICKEN AND THE EGG SO.
MY WIFE WORKS AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE IN THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL --
YOU KNOW FOR OUR STUDENTS THAT
ARE GRADUATING AND WANT TO
WORKING TACK IN THERE'S NO TECH
INDUSTRY.
SO THEY ARE GOING TO LEAVE AND
ARE GOING TO GO TO THE SILICON
VALLEY THEY'RE GOING TO GO --
TO THE COAST BOSTON AND THEY'LL
GO I THINK.
AS WE GRAPPLE WITH THIS HOUSING
ISSUE AND AFFORDABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO REALIZE
THAT THAT'S ALSO --
A CHOICE THAT THEY'RE MAKING --
YOU KNOW WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
MAKE THE MOST MONEY EARLY ON IN
THEIR CAREERS HOW AFFORDABLE IS
CALIFORNIA --
YOU NO MATTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
THAT -- A
HOUSE IN NORCO IT'S THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND RIGHT ACROSS THE
LINE -- THE
SAME HOUSE.
GAINES ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND BY JUST BEING AND AND
AN ORANGE COUNTY YOU DIDN'T EVEN
PAINTED IT'S THE SAME HOUSE
RIGHT --
THAT THAT THAT HAS A LIMITING
FACTOR SO I THINK IT IS THE
EDUCATION WE'RE PRODUCING VERY
WELL EDUCATED --
INDIVIDUALS --
BUT WE HAVE TO INCENTIVIZE
BUSINESS TO SAY OKAY WELL THERE
ARE REGIONS WHERE IT'S CHEAPER
TO DO BUSINESS --
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE WORK FORCE THAT
THEY NEED --
BUT IT'S A HOLISTIC APPROACH
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE.
OTHER ISSUES OF OF OF ALSO
AFFECTING --
THAT THAT THAT GROUP THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
SO IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR SO ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WAS
PRESENT IT WAS ABOUT RESTORING
AND MANUFACTURING AND HOW TO
REMOVE THESE BARRIERS AND SO --
AS THE FORMER SPEAKER JUST SAID
YOU KNOW THERE ARE MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT PAIN POINTS --
TO IT TRACK TEAM BUSINESS
INVESTMENT INTO CALIFORNIA
THAT'S PROBABLY OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OF THIS COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION.
AND PROBABLY CAN TAKE ITS OWN
HEARING --
BUT GIVEN THE FACT AS OR AS AN
INDUSTRY ARE HEIGHTENED EXPOSURE
TO OUT OF STATE COMPETITION IT'S
HARD TO JUST CHOOSE ONE OR TWO
PARTICULAR AREAS --
THAT COULD BE LIKE A SILVER
BULLET TO REMOVING THESE
BARRIERS IT'S THE WHOLE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF OF THE END
OF THE IMPACT THAT WE FEEL AS AS
COMPANIES --
THAT MAKE IT CHALLENGING.
FOR WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
HOW TO ATTRACT SOME ADDITIONAL
MANUFACTURING INVESTMENT I ALSO
THINK IT'S NOTEWORTHY TO POINT
OUT THAT WHILE WE'RE SEEING RE
SHORING AND WE'RE SEEING MORE
MANUFACTURING INVESTMENT I THINK
IT'S UPWARDS OF 12% NATIONWIDE.
CALIFORNIA'S HALF OF THAT SO IT
IS A TIMELY CONVERSATION TO TO
THINK ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS.
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO OUR
INDUSTRY BECAUSE WE ARE UNIQUE --
SO HAVING SAID THAT
MANUFACTURERS NEED CERTAINTY AND
WE NEED PREDICTABILITY IN ORDER
TO THRIVE --
WE ENCOURAGE POLICYMAKERS TO
LOOK AT SPECIFIC PROBLEMS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND SOLUTIONS FOR
THOSE INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
ATTACK THE NARROW IN ISOLATED
INCIDENTS IN THESE BROAD
SWEEPING POLICY AND MISSION S. --
THAT ARE INCOME NATURE OF OUR
MANUFACTURING --
OPERATIONS --
MANUFACTURING IS IN UNIQUE WE'RE
NOT LIKE THE SERVICE INDUSTRIES
WE'RE NOT LIKE YOU KNOW THE
PROFESSIONAL --
OFFICE INDUSTRIES THAT YOU SEE --
OUR COMPETITION IS GLOBAL OUR
JOBS ARE REQUIRE HIGH SKILL OUR
OPERATIONS ARE IT HERE TOO
STRICT PRODUCTION SCHEDULES --
OR BUT OUR MANUFACTURING JOBS
SUPPORT TWO POINT FIVE
ADDITIONAL JOBS IN THE ECONOMY
FOR EVERYONE MANUFACTURING JOB
THAT'S TWO POINT FIVE ADDITIONAL
JOBS THAT WERE CREATING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ARE OPERATIONS AS I SAID BEFORE
OUR SMALL THEY'RE NIMBLE.
AND FRANKLY ARE CALIFORNIA
CUSTOMERS CAN BE SERVICED FROM
ANYWHERE.
SO UNDERSTANDING THE UNIQUENESS
OF MANUFACTURING IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO EXPLORE
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR
ARE TWO TOP PRIORITIES THIS YEAR
OUR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WE'RE
LOOKING AT WAYS TO BRING BACK
INCENTIVIZE --
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
MANUFACTURING AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT WAYS TO BUILD OUT A SKILLED
WORK FORCE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS ABOUT INCOME
INEQUALITY AND TO SHOW THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WHILE WE ARE
BOTH USERS AND MAKERS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY.
WE ALSO HAVE A PLAN OF HOW OUR
WORKERS CAN WORK ALONGSIDE WITH
THAT TECHNOLOGY BUT AGAIN THAT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE EVEN HIGHER
SKILL SET WHICH IS GOING TO
CHALLENGE POLICY MAKERS. TO
INVEST EVEN MORE AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND CAREER GOALS SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
HOPING TO ESTABLISH WITH EITHER.
YOU KNOW WHAT CONVERSATION WITH
THE LEGISLATURE OR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS A
MANUFACTURING COUNCIL BECAUSE WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT INDUSTRY
NEEDS TO BE AT THE TABLE WE
FORECAST THESE TRENDS WE KNOW
THESE --
THESE PATHWAYS NEW OR SURPRISING
TO US BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
ANTICIPATING IT BUT WE NEED A
FORM TO BE ABLE TO SHARE THAT
WITH POLICYMAKERS SO
MANUFACTURING COUNCIL I HEARD
EARLIER YOU KNOW IT'S BEYOND
ADVISORY GROUPS WE TOTALLY AGREE.
BUT WE DO NEED A STATE WIDE
PLACE ONE PLACE SO WE'RE NOT AT
MULTIPLE TABLES WHICH WAS SAID
BEFORE WHERE WE CAN CONVENE AND
WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT IS A
CORNERSTONE INDUSTRY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE LAST POINT I'LL MAKE TO THIS
IS THAT WE OFTEN HEAR
CALIFORNIANS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY.
WE NEED TO OF DEVELOP A NATION
STATE MENTALITY AND IN ORDER TO
HAVE A STRONG AND SUSTAINABLE
NATION STATE WE HAVE TO HAVE A
PRODUCTION INDUSTRY A STRONG AND
SUSTAINABLE PRODUCTION INDUSTRY
THAT'S WHAT MANUFACTORY
REPRESENTS.
AND THAT'S WERE WERE EXCITED TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND TALK WITH
YOU ABOUT THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INSIGHT --
ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS I
WAS TALKING --
TO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IN THE
METAL TRADES INDUSTRY.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE
SAID IS THAT.
A LOT IF NOT MOST OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE MEMBERS BECAUSE
ASSOCIATION HAVE A BACKUP
STRATEGY --
FOR MOVING.
OR FOR EXPANDING WITH ANOTHER
AREA AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT LEGISLATORS UNDERSTAND
[inaudible]
THAT.
IT'S COMPETITION OUT THERE
PEOPLE WANT TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA THESE PEOPLE WANT TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THEIR
BUSINESSES THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND
SO WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS A SAID
IS DEVELOPING BACKUP STRATEGIES
THAT THEY HAVE TO MOVE WORK
AFTER EXPAND WHERE THEY CAN AGO
[inaudible]
MICHIGAN.
SPECIFIC --
TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE
INLAND EMPIRE --
MANY REGIONS HAVE BEEN DOING
WORK WITH THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTE MACKENZIE REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE REGIONAL ECONOMY --
THE INLAND EMPIRE HAS BEEN IN
THAT PROCESS FOR LAST TWO YEARS
IT'S CALLED --
ID GO THE INLAND GROWTH AN
OPPORTUNE.
GROWTH AND OPPORTUNITY
INITIATIVE --
WE'RE ABOUT. TWO MONTHS AWAY
FROM ANNOUNCING --
THE RESULTS OF THAT --
BUT IT REALLY IS --
TELLING US THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON OUR STRENGTHS --
IN CREATING --
COALITIONS --
AROUND WITH OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND OUR PLAYERS IN
OUR BIGGEST --
SECTOR DRIVEN --
PARTS OF THE ECONOMY --
AND SO IN MANUFACTURING OF ANTS
MANUFACTURING IS ONE OF THEM
CERTAINLY THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
SO THAT'S THAT'S COMING.
THANK YOU.
KNOW I KNOW THAT WE HAVE SOME
TIME FOR A FEW MORE QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE OPEN IT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT --
JUST AS A MILLENNIAL IN SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF MILLENNIAL
ENTREPRENEURS OUT --
IT WITH ALL PARTS OF CAL I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE SOME OF THE BEST
MINDS -- OUT
THERE WHO ARE YOUNG MILLENNIALS
AND ARE.
ARE SO CREATIVE INNOVATIVE AND
SUCCESSFUL WHAT CAN THE STATE TO
DO TO PLAY A SUPPORTING ROLE.
TO ASSIST MILLENNIAL
ENTREPRENEURS [inaudible]
GOOD QUESTION.
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE I'VE HAD TO
SO I TURNED FIFTY ONE I DON'T
KNOW WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
DRIVE [inaudible]
SOME -- THE
THIS IN WOMEN THAN I WOULD --
KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR A WHILE --
I I I HAVE LEARNED TO LISTEN TO
MY MILLENNIAL STAFF RIGHT AND
IT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY --
BECAUSE I YOU KNOW --
MY PARENTS AND THE GEN X. RIGHT --
SO THERE WAS A FORMALITY --
MISTRUST SURE --
BUT I WE I THINK WE NEED TO
BETTER TO EACH OTHER I THINK --
BOTH SIDES HAVE A LOT TO ADD
OKAY AND JUST BECAUSE I STILL
LIKE TO GO SHOP --
INSIDE OF YOU KNOW.
OF GROUP THAT STORE RIGHT AND
OTHERS DON'T --
THAT SHOULDN'T SEPARATE US SO I
THINK THAT THERE HAS TO BE SOME
PLACES WHERE WE CAN HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
THAT ARE NOT SO MUCH --
EVERYBODY IN THE CORNER RIGHT
BUT COMING TOGETHER AND SAYING
GOSH WE CAN LEARN A LOT FROM
EACH OTHER --
SO TOTALLY AGREE AND YOUR GREAT
EXAMPLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
ONE OF THE THINGS THIS IMPORT
BECAUSE MILLENNIALS ARE
INTERESTED IN ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AND STARTING BUSINESSES AND
THOSE THOSE KIND OF THINGS --
AND THAT GOES TO THE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL --
ISSUE AND CREATING OPPORTUNITIES
WHERE THEY CAN RAISE START UP
CAPITAL GROWTH CAPITAL --
IT'S IT'S CRITICAL TO THEIR
ABILITY --
TO TO GROW THRIVE EXIST THAT
TECH.
I WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO
PUNCTUATE THAT POINT AND AND
YOURS AS WELL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SOMEONE TASTE. TO TO STATE WHAT
WE'RE SEEING AS FAR AS IN OUR
INNOVATION ECONOMIES WHICH
INCLUDES ADVANCED MANUFACTURING
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING.
YOU'RE SEEING YOUNG PEOPLE GET
EXCITED --
ABOUT THE YOU KNOW ENDLESS
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE ECONOMY AND
STARTING UP THESE LITTLE
COMPANIES IN THEIR GARAGE OR IN
MAKER SPACES SO WE SEE A LOT OF
THAT --
AGAIN TO PUNCTUATE DOT POINT
THAT WHEN THEY'RE STARTING THEY
HAVE DREAMS OF BECOMING BIGGER
OR MORE --
I'M SUCCESSFUL MORE POSPER OF
OF THE ECONOMY SO THEY DO NEED
ACCESS TO CAPITAL THEY DO NEED
OUR SUPPORT --
AND THAT INCLUDES WITH THE WORK
FORCE I CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU HOW
MANY TIMES I RUN IN ON TO
INDIVIDUALS DURING MANUFACTURING
DAVID'S HERE.
IN IN CALIFORNIA IN OCTOBER AND
THEY'RE SAYING YOU KNOW I WANT
TO GROW I WANT EXPAND I WANT TO
BE ABLE TO COMPETE BUT I CAN'T
FIND THE WORK FORCE.
AND SO THE SUPPORT THAT WE GIVE
THEM FOR CAPITAL BECAUSE OF THE
INVESTMENT BUT ALSO FOR CREATING
THIS PIPELINE INTO INDUSTRIAL
TRADE CAN HELP SUPPORT THE
INNOVATION THE INNOVATION.
IS NEEDS TO BE SCALED UP IN ITS
THE SCALING UP OF THAT THAT
PRODUCES THIS PRODUCTION THIS
THIS NATION STATE MENTALITY ALL
GO BACK TO AGAIN.
THAT IF WE'RE JUST SEATING IDEAS
IN CALIFORNIA AND NOT DOING
ANYTHING TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
INTO THE SCALING UP AND
PRODUCTION MASS PRODUCTION OF
THOSE IDEAS WERE GOING TO MISS
OUT ON OPPORTUNITY.
I'D ALSO --
SAY ONE LAST THING.
I NOTICE JUST HEARING FEEDBACK
FROM MY COMPANIES THAT
MILLENNIALS DON'T SEE WORK IN
THE WORLD OF WORK LIKE WE NEED
TO ADD I'M EVEN ON THE EDGE OF
THAT MYSELF FOR I KNOW WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE BEFORE AND I'VE SEEN
THE EVOLUTION.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR NIMBLE
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES AND
FLEXIBILITY THERE LOOKING FOR
LOTS OF ON RAMPS AND OFF RAMPS
BACK AND FORTH INTO CAREER AND
INTO EDUCATION.
SO OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM NEEDS TO
EVOLVE WITH THE EXPECTATION OF
THE MILLENNIALS AND THE
GENERATION TO FOLLOW.
AS TO WHAT THE GOAL OF A EASY IT
IS ASSET AND IS NOT [inaudible]
BUT IT'S CREATING PATHWAYS SO
INDIVIDUALS CAN SEE WELL HOW
THOSE PATHWAYS CAN LEAD TO
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN STAYING SOMEWHERE. FOR TWENTY
FIFTEEN NOT EVEN FIVE YEARS WE
SEE THAT EVEN OUR OUR OWN
CAPITAL COMMUNITY SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
EVOLVES AND AND FOR FEELS THAT
EXPECTATION.
RECORD JUST ADD SOMETHING TO
THAT.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF TECHNOLOGY
I HEAR A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS
SAYING.
INSTEAD OF WE'RE GOING TO GET
THIS TECHNOLOGY AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO TRAIN EVERYBODY TO DO
IT.
THAT THEY'LL JUST GIVE THE TEAM
THE TECHNOLOGY AND THEN THEY'LL
LET THE TEAM FIGURE OUT HOW BEST
TO IMPLEMENT IT --
THAT'S IT THAT'S A BIG CHANGE
AND I THINK THE MORE WE CAN.
LEARN FROM THAT I THINK THE
BETTER OFF WE'LL BE.
WANTED OPEN UP --
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
LAST QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I I
DO HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION BEFORE
WE CLOSE --
WITH THIS SECTION HERE WHAT ARE
THE MOST IMPORTANT ACTIONS THE
STATE CAN TAKE TO SUPPORT.
UPWARD MOBILITY.
SO.
I THINK.
THIS ISSUE OF A REGIONAL FOCUS --
THE NATION STATE IF WE ARE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY --
IF WE WERE A COUNTRY WE ARE I
MEAN THE UNITED STATES --
IN THE DIFFERENT STATES OF THE
UNITED STATES PEOPLE ARE FOCUSED
ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THERE
FOCUSED ON SECTOR BASS
STRATEGIES --
WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT US AS
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY AND DO
THE SAME DO THE SAME IN REGIONS
AS WE APPROACH.
THESE ISSUES OF GROWTH OF
WORKFORCE TRAINING OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE HIT OUR CLIMATE
GOALS -- AND
YET WE MAKE WE WE ARE PROTECTED
IT'S A DIFFERENT WAY OF THINKING
BUT I THINK THAT WOULD.
RISE TO THE TOP OF MY LIST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A COUPLE OF THINGS I'D LIKE TO
SAY ABOUT THAT --
FIRST AND FOREMOST --
A LOT OF THIS IS BEEN FOCUSED ON
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THAT TO ME
IS VERY KEY WE CANNOT ACHIEVE
OUR CLIMATE GOALS WE CAN'T --
TO INNOVATES WE CAN'T --
EXPAND OUR ECONOMY WITHOUT
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE WORK
FORCE THAT REFLECTS THE NEEDS
ARE GOING TO BE IN THE ECONOMY.
SO TO THAT END MATE REALLY MAIN
STREAMING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT NOT SO THAT IT'S A
ONE OFF FOR THAT AFTERTHOUGHT OR
THE THING THAT WE FIND AFTER.
IT TO REALLY BE AN INTEGRATED
PART OF AN EDUCATION EXPERIENCE
WITH TRAINING FOR COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS AGAIN THOSE ON
RAMPS AND OFF RAMPS CREATING
OPTIONS AS YOU MENTIONED BEFORE
SIMPLY MEMBER. FOR INDIVIDUALS
SO THAT THEY CAN YOU KNOW INFO
AT THAT WILL INFORM THEIR CAREER
PATH.
IN THEIR EDUCATION EXPERIENCE
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFE --
THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE YOU KNOW
KIND OF CHANGING THAT THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM THE DELIVERY OF
THE SYSTEM AND ALSO THE FUNDING
MECHANISMS ALSO WE CAN'T HAVE
INSTRUCTION WITHOUT THE TEACHERS.
SO WE NEED TO BUILD OUR WORK
FORCE OF TEACHERS THEY NEED TO
BE EXPERIENCE NOT ONLY IN
ACADEMICS BUT ALSO HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN INDUSTRY IF YOU'RE
GOING TO GET HIGH QUALITY
RELEVANT PROGRAMS.
SO THE PHILS THAT THEY'RE
CONCENTRATED AND THEY NEED TO
HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE AND ALSO
SOME SUPPORT FROM THEIR
STATEWIDE PARTNERS AS WELL.
WE NEED TO DEVELOP IT WAS BUT BE
ON THE TRADITIONAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WHICH IN
OUR INDUSTRY WORKS BETTER FOR
OUR LARGER MANUFACTURERS NOT SO
MUCH FOR OUR SMALL ONES FOR WHAT
I TALKED ABOUT BEFORE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE WHOLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOUNDATION TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE HOURS
THAT NEED TO BE RECORDED THAT
YOU KNOW THAT TRAINING AND
HAVING SOMEBODY BE GONE OUT OF
THE OPERATION FOR CERTAIN
AMOUNTS OF TIMES DURING THE
PRODUCTION SCHEDULE.
SO WE NEED TO HAVE EARNING LEARN
PROGRAMS THAT CAN WORK FOR ALL
INDUSTRIES.
AND FINALLY.
AGAIN I MENTIONED THIS BEFORE IF
WE WANT PEOPLE TO SUCCEED AND TO
HAVE SUSTAINABLE CAREERS WITH
LIVABLE WAGES CALIFORNIA MUST
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLEGE A AND CAREER.
THE GOAL OF OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
SHOULD NOT BE A COLLEGE DEGREE
IT SHOULD BE A SUCCESSFUL AND
FULFILLING AND SUSTAINABLE
CAREER AND NOT WILL ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE OPTIONS THEY
CAN CHOOSE THEIR OWN PATHWAYS.
AND THEY WILL REALLY FEEL
EMPOWERED AND BE ABLE --
TO ENGAGE AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
ECONOMY ECONOMY IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY -- I'D
LIKE TO REEMPHASIZE THE ASPECT
OF EDUCATION.
AND COLLEGE RUSSES.
APPRENTICESHIP AND THAT THAT
TAPE WITH ME IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE A INTERNAL
BATTLE WITHIN THE DIFFERENT
SECTORS.
OF THE COMMUNITY OF THESE PEOPLE
I KNOW I WAS INVOLVED.
IN AND I EVEN FORGET WHAT THE
ORGANIZATION WAS BUT I HAD THE
GUY CALLED ME UP AND HE SAID THE
GUY WHO WAS THE HEAD OF THE
COMMUNITY.
AND HE SAID SO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD BE THE
FOCUS OF EDUCATION?
AND HIS BAND WAS COLLEGE.
AND DO IS AN INTERNAL BATTLE
GOING ON THAT'S GOT TO STOP --
THERE'S A PLACE FOR BOTH.
MEDICS IMPORTANT THAT WE
EMPHASIZE THAT THERE'S A ROLE
FOR COLLEGE THERE'S A ROLE FOR
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIR
TO ROSE FOR FRIENDSHIPS.
AND THOSE THOSE ALL NEED TO BE.
TOGETHER AND WORK ON TOWARDS
REACHING TE FINAL.
I AGREE VENTURE IT IF I COULD
JUST OUT ONE LAST THING --
I DON'T KNOW TO PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT AND PERSPECTIVE SO I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT ALL OF YOU.
BUT IF MY PLUMBING GOES OUT IF
MY CAR STOPS WORKING IF MY ROOF
STARTS LEAKING IF THE
ELECTRICITY DOESN'T WORK IN MY
HOUSE OF MY SOLAR SYSTEM.
GOES DOWN MY LAW DEGREE IS NOT
GOING TO HELP ME IN FIXING ANY
OF THAT AND THE NARRATIVE IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT THAT WE AS AS
POLICY MAKERS HAVE CREATED THE
NARRATIVE.
THAT COLLEGE IS THE IT'S THAT
THE BIGGEST BARRIER TO KIND OF
BUILDING THIS SKILLED WORKFORCE
IS THE NARRATIVE THAT WE PUT OUT
AND THAT HAS BEEN ADOPTED. TO TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN START
REALLY FOCUSING ON COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS AND REALLY
MAKING THE GOAL OF EDUCATION.
A CAREER A SUCCESSFUL
SUSTAINABLE LIVING WAGE
PRODUCING CAREER THEN I THINK WE
WILL HELP TO KIND OF ROLL BACK
SOME OF THESE BIASES.
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND THEN
START CREATING THIS WELL ROUNDED
SOCIETY WHERE YOU HAVE ACADEMICS
AND YOU HAVE TECHNICAL SKILLS
WORKING TOGETHER.
WONDERFUL WELL I I DO WANT TO
CLOSE I'D THIS SO --
PANEL BY SAYING THANK YOU TO
EACH OF YOU FOR PARTICIPATING
AND MAKING YOUR WAY --
FROM ALL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA TO
BE HERE IN SACRAMENTO FOR THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING --
I WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS --
IF THERE ARE THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK UP PLEASE.
STEP FORWARD. TWENTY OVER THERE.
MIKE.
I THOUGHT MY GUESS WHAT YES THAT
THAT IT WORKS AS WELL.
OKAY.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
STATE STATE YOUR NAME AND THE
ORGANIZATION YOUR WITH YES THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LAURIE KAMMERER I'M AT
ALSO.
SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA BUT I
ALSO REPRESENT THE NOW NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS CALIFORNIANS SACRAMENTO
VALLEY AND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
METALS COALITION --
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT WAS
SAID I GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
HEARING THAT YOU PUT ON TODAY --
I THINK THAT --
LOOKING AT ADD.
MAYBE BRINGING IN SOME OF THE
LABOR FOLKS MY IN IN WORKING
WITH.
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
EVERYTHING --
I ALSO WANTED INDICATE TO THAT --
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF BILLS
SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA IS A
SPONSORING IN TERMS OF ACCESS TO
CAPITAL --
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE NOT JUST
NON UNION COMPANIES BUT ALSO
UNION COMPANIES WHO HAVE
FINISHED THEIR APPRENTICE
PROGRAMS WHO HAVE --
FINISH THEIR JOURNEY UP PROGRAMS
AND WHO ARE READY TO START A
SMALL BUSINESS SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OUR
UNION PARTNERS IN IN THE WHOLE --
ACCESSING CAPITAL SO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF RACE HAS A A
BILL THAT WOULD IT INCREASE
FUNDING TO COPE IS FOR START UP
COMPANIES.
AND THEN ALSO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT A OR THAT WOULD ALSO ALLOW
CROWD FUNDING TO HELP SOME OF
THE UNION NON UNION COMPANY SO
WE APPRECIATE YOUR HEARING TODAY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE FUTURE.
LIKE YOUR COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
JOHN CAB ATTACK I AM.
CALIFORNIA STATE DIRECTOR ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS PRE SHEET THIS
DISCUSSION THAT THAT WAS A GREAT
DISCUSSION IN VERY MUCH AGREED
WITH EVERYTHING.
WHO SHARED APPRECIATE THAT
COUPLE JUST A COUPLE THOUGHTS ON
TOP OF MY HEAD BOTH --
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AND ALSO AS
A PARENT OF TWO HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA --
ONE THOUGHT AS IT RELATES TO THE
IT INCREASING THE IMPRINT
APPRENTICESHIPS IN THE BUILDING
TRADES AND JUST ASKING TO KEEP
IN MIND OTHER AREAS SUCH AS A
RESTAURANT TRADES RETAIL SO MANY
OTHER AREAS THAT REALLY NEED
SKILLED WORKERS.
THOUGHT THAT CAME TO MY MIND
THAT WOULD BE GREAT WOULD BE YOU
KNOW I JUST THINKING OF MY BET
YEARS BACK IN HIGH SCHOOL IN
SOUTHERN CAL AND UP HERE WITH MY
CHILDREN EVEN NOW --
TO THE EXTENT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INCENTIVIZE SMALL
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND HE MAY BE
BACK EVEN TO MIDDLE SCHOOL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER FAIRS
AND EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES I
THINK EVEN AS FAR BACK IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL WHEN.
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
THINK ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HIGH SCHOOL JOBS --
THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY --
TRANSLATE INTO YES IT'S ALWAYS
GREAT TO SEE THE THE LARGER
CORPORATIONS AND BUSINESSES SHOW
UP BUT TO THE EXTENT THERE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES.
ARE MEMBER SCOTT'S AND OTHERS
THAT COULD BE INCENTIVIZE
SOMEHOW I JUST A TOP OF MIND TOP
IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE ALSO HEARD
FROM SOME PEOPLE.
A SECOND COMMENT WAS JUST VERY
QUICKLY WAS YOU ASKED ABOUT HOW
TO MAKE REGULATIONS SMARTER --
AND MAKE THEM MORE EFFECTIVE I
COULD NOT IN AGREE WITH SCOTT
HOW CAN MORE THAN I THINK A LOT
OF THE AGENCIES AREN'T TALKING
TO EACH OTHER OFTENTIMES SO TO
THE EXTENT.
THERE'S A CHANCE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A LOT OF DIALOGUE HERE
WITHIN THE CAPITAL BUT TO THE
EXTENT THERE'S A CHANCE TO TALK
TO THE LEAGUE TO THE C. SACK.
TO RURAL COUNTIES ASSOCIATION
AND OTHERS AND THEN FRANKLY --
FOLKS AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THIS IS A MUST BE A MULTI LEVEL
AT A DISCUSSION ABOUT --
THESE CONFLICTS COMPLETELY AS
I'M SURE YOU'VE HELP STIMULATE
SOME OF THAT DISCUSSION BUT TO
THE EXTENT THOSE THREE LEVELS
CAN HAVE MORE OF A DIALOGUE TO
BE GREAT AND IT FINALLY JUST TO
THE EXTENT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE.
RIGHT TO CORRECT PERIODS I THINK
OFTENTIMES THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION
THAT A RIGHT TO CORRECT PERIOD
MEANS THAT.
EMPLOYERS SMALL EMPLOYERS ARE
ANY LEVEL OR JUST TRYING TO GET
AROUND A LOT THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
JUST SO BUSY IN THEIR DAY TO DAY
AS SCOTT MENTIONED IN IS A A TO
HURT OTHER STATES PAUL AND
OTHERS SAY TODAY.
SO THAT RIGHT TO CORRECT PERIOD
WHETHER IT'S OSHA --
VIA VIOLATIONS ORAL ALLEGATIONS
OR YOU KNOW LOT LEGAL AREAS --
THE EXTENT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE SMALL
EMPLOYERS TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT WHAT WHAT THEY MAY OR MAY
NOT BE DOINGWRONG AND HAVE A
CHANCE TO CORRECT IT.
I THINK MOST OF THEM ARE WILLING
TO DO THAT SO APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME IN THIS DISCUSSION AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING I JUST WANT TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF I'M DAVID
NELSON --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE NEW STATEWIDE
LIAISON FOR THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS --
WE'VE BEEN SO GRACIOUS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OVER THE YEARS AND AND
I'M JUST MORE HERE TO INTRODUCE
MYSELF TO LISTEN TO LEARN AND TO
FIND OUT HOW WE CAN BE.
A PARTNER ONLY LISTENING PARTNER
BUT AT THE TO THE GROUND PARTNER
IN A RESOURCE --
AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT THINGS
REGIONALLY AS YOU KNOW WE ARE
DIVIDED REGIONALLY WE HAVE FIVE
REGIONS --
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA
AND WE ALSO HAVE ECONOMIC IMPACT
REPORTS WHICH HAVE ALL BEEN
UPDATED FOR EVERY ASSEMBLY
SENATE AND CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
RESULTED ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO
SO I'M HAPPY --
TO BE AVAILABLE TO YOU AT ANY
TIME -- I'M
LOCATE HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND MY
REGIONAL DIRECTORS COME UP ONCE
A MONTH BUT REALLY AM EXCITED TO
BE HERE AND TO LISTEN AND TO BE
RESOURCE TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU THINK HERE.
GOOD MORNING BLOOD SHEPHERD
REPRESENTING THE CAL ASIAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THAT WE
REPRESENT OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND BUSINESS A. B. I.
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND WE JUST WANNA REITERATE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS CONVERSATION IS
WE ARE FOLLOWING WORK FORCE --
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES AND HOW WE
ADDRESS WORKFORCE AND A SKILLS
GAP -- AND
WE LOOK FORWARD --
TO HAVING MORE AS MORE BILLS
COME THROUGH AND WE JUST
APPRECIATE THIS HEARING THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DAVID SPAR --
A MEMBER OF THE KHALLID ORDER
DIRECTORS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND I'M A COMMUNITY ENTREPRENEUR --
I AGREE WITH WHAT WAS PRESENTED
HERE TODAY I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ADD AND MAYBE OFFER HELP.
THE CHAIR ANSWER THE QUESTION OF
HOW DO WE TRANSCEND HOW DOES THE
STATE TRANSCEND SOME OF THESE
ISSUES.
NUMBER ONE IS TO ASK --
CALIFORNIA FORWARD TO BRING BACK
THEIR DREAM INDEX.
NUMBER TO THE CALIFORNIA --
WORK FOR SPORT TO BRING BACK --
LOWERING BARRIERS TO ENTRANCE
FOR PARTNERSHIP AND CALIFORNIA
AND NUMBER THREE EDGE ON HOW TO
LOWER BARRIERS.
GETTING INTO EDUCATION AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND USING
THINGS SUCH AS CLEP EXAMS --
STANDARDIZING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO -- THE
UNITS FROM ONE COLLEGE ARE
ACCEPTED BY ANOTHER COLLEGE.
AND WITH A CALIFORNIA STATE
COLLEGES ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THEY LIKE TO HAVE THEIR OWN IN
THEIR OWN DISTRICT.
YOU NEED TO ELIMINATE THAT AND
ACCEPT ALL EDUCATION SO IS
TRANSFERABLE I THINK WE NEED
BOTH THE CAREERS.
AND I THINK WE NEED --
COLLEGE ALSO WHAT WAS MENTIONED
IS -- WHAT
ARE MILLENNIALS LOOKING?
FOR HELLO BARRIER OF ENTRY.
WHETHER IT'S INTO THE WORK FORCE
OR INTO A CAREER OR EDUCATION.
SO WE OUGHT NOT BE TAXING CELL
PHONES AND THE INTERNET OR OVER
TAXING IT IN CREATING MORE
BARRIERS.
WITH SMALL BUSINESS IT'S THE
BARRIERS AND TO THE MARKET PLACE.
OVERCOMING STATE REGULATION
LOCAL REGULATION EMPLOYMENT IN
HIRING AND MONITORING AND ACCESS
TO CAPITAL WITH LARGE INDUSTRY.
ITS BARRIERS TO THE MARKET PLACE
THEY'RE ALL LOOKING FOR TALENT.
THEY WILL PAY MORE MONEY THEY
WILL LOCATE IN CALIFORNIA EVEN
THOUGH IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE.
IF IN RETURN THERE'S A TALENTED
WORKFORCE THEIR TALENTED
WORKFORCE CAN COME FROM HIGH
SCHOOL CAN COME FROM CREE ATTACK
CAN COME FROM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
WORKING COME FROM A COLLEGE.
IT'S ONE WHO HAS EXPERIENCE.
AND ONE WHO IS WILLING TO WORK.
ARE YOU SE WERE NOT PROVIDING
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITY OR EXPOSING
THEM TO OPPORTUNITY SO THEY HAVE.
ACCESS TO THE MARKET PLACE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NOW I DO WANT TO MENTION THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN COMMENTS TO THE JOBS
COMMITTEE UNTIL APRIL.
TWENTY UNTIL APRIL FIFTEENTH OF
THIS YEAR --
I WANT TO CLOSE BY AND I HOPE
YOU FOUND THIS HEARING TO BE A
SOLID FIRST STEP --
AND DEVELOPING SOUND ECONOMIC
POLICIES THAT CREATE JOBS
SUPPORT ENTREPRENEURS AND EXPAND
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I WANT TO THANK ALL
WHO PROVIDED A TESTIMONY OR
WITNESSES ARE SPEAKERS I WANT TO
THANK MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S.
HEARING AND FOR THE PUBLIC AS
WELL FOR YOUR COMMENTS AT THIS
MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED